ladies and gentlemen do not adjust your
television it is really 2023 and for the
first time in history a president is
being indicted and will face criminal
charges this is all just such great
views such great news I was proven even
more right than I would have ever
imagined because apparently you know
there is actually igniting my father so
great orange leader maybe I was wrong
maybe prayer does work
right communist level this is
[Music]
communist level basically
this is like communist level
communist level great orange leader
Dear God
forbid Donnie boy God forbid Donny boy
dear God
God forbid Donnie boy God forbid Donny
boy
great communist
spaces
like communist little this is
communist level of
this is
communist level
I think that's about all we need to hear
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets and shows
10 times 15 times
[Music]
what on Earth is going on with Trump
toilet
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation the big massive dumps
10 times
[Music]
bathrooms
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms then he
went Donald Trump killed Donald Trump I
love Donald Trump but no more dropped by
the drop boxes are just so bad no more
drop boxes Dickinson hologic and cephe
cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth Central
he voted against Kate's law and he voted
for Obama
you know we've endorsed Dr Oz we've
endorsed JP right JD Mandel and he's
doing great I've had more investigations
and Jesse James Billy the good some of
the world's greatest cricket players
from
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come on what's that
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infant trip and badge for his
service we have to keep our country gay
people but it's not I mean for some
reason it's just not great anymore if
you care about law and auto look Law and
Order in normal times roughly 40 percent
of fresh vegetables at about 40 percent
China nambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President Ulysses S
Grant he's done he's really come back a
long way over the last 10 years hasn't
he
very much Jim Apple when they gaze upon
your semites your seminites towering
sequoias they deliver they swept and
swept in you know that sweeping it was
Swift and it was sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasma into
failing New York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading woman's business who teach
you should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children well enough
correct of himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you've heard them and you know them well
well ladies and gentlemen we are here on
what we know is the first but it may not
be the last arrest and indictment of the
failed former president Donald Trump we
are monitoring multiple feeds and I
can't tell you the degree of pleasure
that it gives me to have you here with
me today we are monitoring multiple
feeds where we are now is that the
arraignment the arrest booking and
arraignment are scheduled for about an
hour and 24 minutes from now 2 15 p.m
eastern time in the East 11 15 a.m
Eastern uh Pacific Time excuse me
um and this potentially the first of
only many arrests and indictments and it
may be the first of all for the first of
two streams today we may be streaming
Trump's Mar-A-Lago
um
I don't know what to call it something
later today any moment now Donald Trump
will leave Trump Tower and he will head
to the courthouse and the process will
begin some will tell you this is a sign
that there is no justice in the United
States but I would tell you something
very different I would tell you that
this is a sign that even when you are
the president of the United States if
you are a one-man crime spree the likes
of which we've never seen before in the
Oval Office you were not above the law
that is Justice to me
and of course
you might agree you might disagree let's
take a look at all of the different
things we are monitoring CNN
has uh various views here and any moment
we are going to see uh Trump leave now I
did want to get some better video
quality for all of you I respect you too
much to have this low end video quality
here but I'm sure we will work on that
we are monitoring a feed just outside
the courthouse as you can see officers
lining the streets these are Court
officers
uh
uh oh this is right by my old apartment
it looks like
yeah
um Court officers a lot going on Newsmax
is covering the entire thing I believe
that well actually I think both of these
shots are near Trump Tower
um this is a shot right outside Trump
Trump Tower at street level
for some reason we don't understand
right side broadcasting which has spent
days promoting their live stream
the lot the stream never started it's
unclear what's going on I'll refresh
just to see but maybe some issues over
it right side broadcasting could be
possible trouble in Paradise let's look
at a couple of different things that
have been going on today uh there was a
conflict at the protest today where a
trump supporter rushed and anti-trump
banner and started attacking the
protesters look at this
so this woman in the red Maga hat if you
weren't sure which one was the protester
it's this woman in the red Maga she's
trying to rip up the thing
you're on the wrong side
[Music]
oh my God
she's gonna crack pipe someone yelled
something makes me think that that
person wasn't close enough to actually
see whether there was a crack pipe there
but that is that is pretty damn funny I
have to say
come on
wow
this event clearly bringing out
absolutely the best in people
someone just yelled out violent
communist agitators
[Music]
does your name
ma'am what did you say your name was
Marjorie Taylor green yes I'm from
Georgia exactly uh all right so it's as
you can see it is going to be an insane
insane day ahead of us it is hard to
even keep up with all of it Newsmax
asking the question we've all been
asking Trump indictment real crimes or
just politics and you can vote now
apparently
very very compelling stuff and here we
are right outside of Trump Tower and we
will keep it here for a moment and we
will
all right let's uh see where we go next
okay so here's the roughly the schedule
for today any moment Trump is expected
to leave Trump Tower and go over to the
courthouse the arraignment is expected
at 2 15 PM eastern time there will be no
video cameras in the courtroom there
will be still Photography in the
courtroom uh there was initially the
sense that there would be a mug shot
more recently the reporting is there
will be no mug shot
that's what I've been seeing today
uh Super Chat Carson says cheers from
Australia welcome there is activity
right now that is Jason Miller uh
involved in getter and maybe involved in
truth Central as you can see he looks
extremely professional and he's leaving
so it seems as though I don't know where
he's going that is that Jason Miller
guys is that true
I'm just going by face but I don't
actually know for sure that look
certainly looked like Jason Miller to me
it is Jason Miller okay very good uh we
do have the coupon code indicted we are
we are here with the code indicted big
thanks to Nathan huning and Greg Watts
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code indicted if we get to
250 I will stream Trump's mayor alago
press conference tonight
all right everybody very much appreciate
that uh and welcome everybody watching
over on Twitch and people dumping in
some twitch subscriptions looks like one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen
17 18 19 19 plus two I believe is twenty
one and it does appear as though any
moment now any moment now Donald Trump
will be heading over to the courthouse
other super chats coming in I see they
brought the wambulance they do have an
ambulance standing by in Florida women
got arrested for peacefully protesting
against restrictive abortion laws
fascism is on its way greetings from
Germany
scary stuff
sir do you think if Trump stuffed the
indicated down the toilet and flushed 10
to 15 times it would go away supposedly
Trump did try to to flush the indictment
yeah
here is someone just walking their dog
right through the entire scene that's
funny
just a dog
just a dog walker
you never know what you're going to see
in New York City but everybody being
very very polite you love to see it you
really do love to see it CNN is in a
commercial break it looks like there is
now some activity starting at the
courthouse so we're following all of it
right side broadcasting still not live
let's look at a few uh videos from on
the ground we have a bunch of different
things here that I'd like to take a look
at
um let's see what we have here
we kicked Marjorie Taylor green out of
New York City oh this I have to see
[Music]
yourself for the main event so Marjorie
Taylor green is like in a crush and she
seems to have a megaphone with a
handheld microphone
and it seems as though it's just not
happening first I've been patiently
waiting it's like the AIDS test what's
the results not positive oh wow the
whistle Brigade made it impossible to
even hear Marjorie Taylor green oh my
goodness look at this who's the best
nothing big ain't no
she doesn't stand a chance
[Music]
the whistle as a non-violent way to shut
down
uh someone I mean guys remember listen
I'm not taking a position for or against
speech it's all speech okay the whistles
are speech and Marjorie Taylor Green's
megaphone or speech visually I find it
really funny
blocks since 9-1 I am the truth name a
rapper that I ain't influenced wow that
is really something here's a guy wearing
a noose about Alvin Bragg
uh let's see what else we have
the reason you can't hear Marjorie
Taylor green is because a man has been
handing out oh my goodness this guy just
brought whistles for everybody
to uh the whistles where'd you get that
idea huh where'd you get the idea for
whistles
wow it seems that it's a pro-trump guy
who was handing out the whistles and it
seems to have completely and totally
backfired I mean just a complete and
total backfire on them uh as a result of
not being able to hear a damn thing it's
it's really crazy
um okay we're continuing to monitor the
scene outside Trump Tower and it seems
as though any moment Donald Trump will
leave but I don't want to miss some of
this other stuff that's going on in the
meantime big thank you to Gordon Hall
Alan Eddy and uh
oh Gordon Hall and Alan Eddie for
signing up on my website today's coupon
code is indicted ladies and gentlemen
celebrate with us the code is indicted
you all know why and thanks to the four
folks who just signed up via twitch
Prime let's continue like checking out
the sights and sounds there is a Nazi
here in a skull mask yelling at people
to watch an anti-semitic film okay
sounds about right
let's see what else we have Jamal Bowman
pops off on Marjorie Taylor green
go back to your District what are you
doing here you're here for politics
you're here cause you want to be VP
you're here for your own fundraising
you're here for your own nonsense that's
all true on Fox News they're hoping that
maybe Trump will have a microphone when
he leaves uh when he leaves Trump Tower
which he hasn't done yet we're
monitoring it here is hot Fox news's
sincere hope how how weak this case is
but this is a day they have long hoped
for so Trump wants to speak to the media
just in the hallway outside the
courtroom perhaps before after or both
of those times we know that the Secret
Service is handling him we know that we
will not be seeing him in handcuffs but
he might have a microphone let's hope so
yeah and as you said let's hope so it is
really inspiring to see that Fox News
conservatives are now standing up for
the voices of those being crushed by the
justice system isn't it nice to see that
they now all of a sudden are in defense
of that isn't that great or is it only
because it's Donald Trump he can control
his own message that way he doesn't have
to worry about being manipulated his
words being manipulated by a defiant and
principled Harris Faulkner standing up
for the speech
of trump who is as you know has lost his
speech thank you to Amy lamara Sylvia
Smiley and Stevie Getz for signing up on
my website ladies and gentlemen the code
is indict this is stream number one the
arraignment of trump if we get to 250
website members I will stream again
tonight when Trump holds what will
certainly be an unhinged and possibly
criminal if there's a gag order press
conference about the trial that will be
if it happens around 7 45 PM eastern
time let's review some super chats happy
to support the real news says Lindsay in
a British pounds contribution thank you
I will be in the United Kingdom very
soon
Peter says even if Trump is brought in
front of the judge it's not the be-all
end-all story as we need to know what
every charge is before we get excited or
concerned yes and the reports are that
it is 34 felonies not indictments
felonies earlier Donald Trump's attorney
made a Freudian slip and said president
fraud I saw that very very funny
very funny never been to New York how
far is Trump Tower from the courthouse
by car uh it's not very far but with New
York traffic it could be the difference
between seven minutes or an hour and a
half
um since he probably won't be convicted
I was at least looking for a mug shot
hopefully with no makeup I'm
disappointed but it's a good day now
they don't make you take your makeup off
for a drop for a mug shot as far as I
know
we this close till we can announce the
international holiday when the orange
man got denied future presidencies thank
you Jesus salute from Finland wow
today proves everyone is equal under the
law except for the handcuffs mugshot
Court video commuting contempt of court
and real threat of jail exactly right
out that's exactly right we can now say
that no one is above the law not even
Trump with the exception of a Phalanx of
Cirque Secret Service agents as well as
not being handcuffed not getting a mug
shot not having cameras in the courtroom
and probably getting a gag order that
you're going to violate tonight to
absolutely know uh no punishment
um
I do have my new Candace Owens drop on
the soundboard David pakman does not
have a soul he doesn't have a soul
there you go so we do have that imagine
if this idiot has a gag order and starts
to speak right out of court and gets
arrested again on the spot I know that
would be a delight
can't wait for the Candace Owens no soul
clip oh wow I didn't even know Johnny
about that super chat but I just gave it
to you there whoops hold on that's the
wrong one David Pacman does not have a
soul he doesn't have a soul Marjorie
Taylor green did that crap on purpose
check out her MSNBC interview she was
gleeful all right we'll see if we can
find it this is a good day for democracy
says safflower oil safflower oil folks
thank you to everyone who is here we are
moments away from the arraignment of
Donald Trump this video is at Trump
Tower Trump expected to leave any moment
we are monitoring CNN let's listen right
now
hold on let's let's actually listen door
and about to come outside I believe one
of his top AIDS uh Jason Miller has been
cited yep CNN's Paula Reed is outside
the Manhattan Criminal Courts Building
and Paula uh you'll forgive me if I
interrupt uh when Mr Trump appears but
Mr tell us more about the Trump legal
team with whom you've been texting all
morning what have they been saying to
you about the pending indictment
well the legal team is expanding
yesterday they added Todd Blanche a very
experienced defense attorney to the team
by the way we can still hear the
whistles going in the background but it
appears Jake to just be The Logical Next
Step this has gone from being an
investigation to being a full-blown
criminal prosecution the former
president is going to need all the help
he can get also some questions about
what this Edition meant for Joe takapina
who has been the most forward-facing
member of the defense team and Joe tells
me he is still on the team he expects to
be the lead counsel at today's hearing
which could make sense because Todd has
only been on the case for about 24 hours
but I made all these questions about who
is the lead I will note that it's the
other lawyer it's almost like Trump only
recently realized this actually requires
true lawyers who can try a case in court
the former president has historically
had lawyers who defend him in court and
then also lawyers who defend him on TV
right takapino is someone who can do
both Todd Blanche is a necklace are
fantastic attorneys who can help the
former president by the way Joe takapina
previously said Trump's guilty before he
was working for Trump he actually said
it seems as though Trump committed a
crime here once they know what exactly
this case is all about
all right Paul Reed thank you so much
this reporting I'm realizing that that
seems to have been eight minutes behind
let's refresh that was weird it was like
eight minutes okay let's let's see if we
can actually get that going again being
a defendant or a plaintiff in a Civil
Trial is very much more at your and your
attorney there we go now we are caught
up very good thank you for the person
who pointed that out I very much
appreciate that big thank you to Tom
Brader John demartin Sunny Place Stephen
Hill David Graham Sunny place with
another gifted membership and uh big
thank you to Brad Scholl and Julie
glotsbach folks the memberships are
dumping in we are here celebrating that
no one is above the law within reason
and that Donald Trump is being arraigned
and indicted the coupon code at
joinpakman.com is indeed the word
indicted let's continue looking
at some of the super chats can the David
packman show place a bid on the
courtroom sketch from today could be a
fun souvenir might be too rich for my
blood it looks as though they are now
Gathering and getting into the vehicles
Donald Trump probably wait it's about
four miles
uh where he is at Trump Tower uh down to
the Manhattan court building which is in
the southern part of Manhattan Island
I'm sure we'll bring that uh tape back
again to show it to people uh go ahead
Abby I'm sorry I didn't interrupted no I
just just to point out that this could
be a stacking of indictments against him
it could be a stacking of allegations
against him and there may not be a res I
think one of the arguments politically
that his aides make is that uh you know
if Alvin Bragg is humiliated in this
case it really undermines the other
cases well we may not know for a little
while and those other cases are going to
proceed because those prosecutors have
to make their own charging decisions
about how this goes and off they go
again Donald Trump on his way to court
James said it best earlier he will be
under arrest in an hour or so that's not
a good thing I'm sorry maybe Donald
Trump knows no shame you mentioned that
earlier maybe it's not a good thing okay
what does that mean all right here we've
got another better shot
David if you blinked you would have
missed his departure he gave a brief
wave to the crowd and then got right
into that motorcade all right ladies and
gentlemen the motorcade is on the move
the former president of the United
States may be one of the worst
Presidents of the United States will
soon be under arrest in a Manhattan
Courthouse
steps from uh well not too far from the
stock exchange
he is indeed on the Move welcome
everybody I am so glad that you were
with us today the this is quite a
historic day the uh motorcade making its
way down there will be sort of uh
concentric circles of security around
Donald Trump of course there will be
NYPD of course there will be Court
officers and there will will also be
secret service secret service will be
protecting the man who is about to get
arrested and that is at this point the
reality where we find ourselves I know
there are many in the audience with
tears in their eyes and as we know
something about Donald Trump just makes
big strong guys burst into tears as all
of the different stories go let's uh
let's listen stronger opinion about it
you have a handful of people maybe who
have signs in support of trump but even
they are not protesting in any way
certainly a historic day in for
Americans the native New Yorker who
grew up here and found a lot of Fame and
prominence yeah it's sort of poetic the
story for Trump starts in New York and
he gets arrested in New York fascinating
for this day of
face the judge and be fingerprinted but
interestingly David you know as you know
he had urged his supporters to protest
suggesting that there might be potential
death and destruction we are seeing none
of that yeah none of his followers seem
to actually care Warren people uh
outside Trump Tower is Lindsay aptly put
it if you blinked you missed it the
former president leaving Trump Tower
very quickly getting into the motorcade
again the Secret Service assisting but
the NYPD taking the lead here today as
they make that four mile trip now down
to lower Manhattan and the criminal
court obviously it will not take nearly
as long as it would take in a typical
day in Manhattan traffic has been
cleared away uh so have pedestrians in
many parts of New York to to make this
trip as efficient as possible for the
former president in making his way to
lower Manhattan we are getting new
reporting this morning on what will play
out this afternoon here in New York
our senior investigative reporter Aaron
kutursky live outside the courthouse
Aaron take us through what we know so
far what the American people will
witness what we won't see and how this
arraignment will unfold here
David former president Trump is on his
way here to surrender as the defendant
in the people of the state of New York
against Donald J Trump he's going to
arrive here at the criminal Courthouse
through a side entrance that has already
been blocked off in anticipation of his
arrival all of the cars including the
District Attorney's vehicle have been
cleared from the Block so the president
can come in unencumbered he's
immediately going to be taken inside to
the district attorney's office for
processing where he will be formally
placed under arrest and processed and
booked as a criminal defendant a short
time later he will be taken to the 15th
floor to a courtroom where he will be
arraigned we're told he's going to use a
special elevator ordinarily reserved for
the judges and that will put him right
at the entrance to the courtroom so he
may only be in the hallway a few minutes
just mere steps once inside he will be
seated in The Well of the courtroom and
that is something the American people
have never seen a former occupant of the
Oval Office seated at the defense table
of a criminal courtroom surrounded by
his lawyers Susan necklace and Todd
Blanche of former Federal prosecutor who
was recently added to the defense team
there will be no television cameras
inside the judge wouldn't allow it but
David he is allowing a number of
photographers to snap pictures for a few
minutes before the arraignment begins so
we will undoubtedly see the former
president seated there and I'm curious
about some of these Dynamics there will
indeed be Dynamics okay we have gotten a
different CNN feed that I think is
better because it's on YouTube this will
help us
okay
uh I guess that one doesn't really have
audio and then we do want to keep an eye
on what's happening on Fox news but
they're just running a lot of different
commercials so we'll see what we can do
about that monitoring other feeds this
is the scene at the courthouse this is
where they are awaiting the arrival of
trump you see the Associated Press tent
you see
um photographers and a few people
holding signs and different things
Newsmax continues to cover this they are
also tracking Trump's path down
seemingly the east side of Manhattan
down to the courthouse uh this is
another shot just outside the courthouse
and right side broadcasting guys I don't
know what happened but it looks like
right side broadcasting has bailed on
the broadcast some are saying ah they
are live on Rumble and Rumble only that
is interesting right side broadcasting
choosing only to go live on Rumble
always very very compelling stuff here
is indeed the motorcade ladies and
gentlemen it is very difficult to keep
up with all of the messages and things
that are going on we have a combination
of people sending me messages about the
indictment people sending me messages
about whether I'm streaming tonight
people sending messages about I thought
that you were canceled
and also people still mad about my tweet
like about a week and a half ago about a
shooting that took place in Nashville so
we're trying to keep up with a lot of
different things the indictment will
soon be unsealed
34 felony counts as the latest news that
we have been told
people talking about Trump nfts
people from Canada are watching great to
see you Cheshire the cat is the Don Jr
stuff performance art or is he that
triggered I think he's that triggered to
be honest
um should the left get guns asks Ryan
we've discussed that I I don't I mean
listen I don't think the rights should
be the only people with the guns what
was my opinion of trump before he ran
for president uh I didn't have much of
an opinion of him just
he never struck me as a guy that should
be president I guess is what I would say
a mug shot will make a great campaign
poster I know I think Trump wanted a mug
shot and wanted to actually be
handcuffed which is incredible if you're
just joining us this is a historic day
Donald Trump is moments away
is that a hearse what the hell Donald
Trump is moments away from arriving in
court in lower Manhattan looking like
they are on the FDR heading south
passing some of the
I don't know if it's still appropriate
but iconic housing projects of New York
City and Manhattan that everybody coming
into the city knows as you go south on
FDR Drive you see them on your right
side
um looking now like we are getting this
looks like it's pretty South already I
think I already saw them pass at least
one of the bridges so we're getting
pretty pretty close here
um and somehow it got unsynced there we
go uh so it's all it's all happening
it's all happening major major
construction happening in lower
Manhattan as everybody can see thank you
to everyone I see people signing up with
the coupon code indicted it is crazy
it's impossible to even keep up three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen Seventeen additional members
that's a pretty big membership dump
putting us at 71. tonight 7 45 Eastern I
may be streaming Trump's press
conference from Mar-A-Lago back in
Florida if we get to the 250 number
let's listen and see what the latest
reporting is John Santucci who reported
off air on the Trump campaign leading up
to 2016 and then on the Trump years in
the presidency John our thanks to you
with us all afternoon here along with
Catherine folders and our entire
political team standing by also our
reporters from New York City to
Washington to West Palm Beach where the
president will end this day the former
president and he is set in Mar-A-Lago to
brief reporters again at the end of this
historic day though even though they've
worked on what he will say likely that
could be tweet given the temperature of
what plays out in this courtroom here
this morning this is a surreal scene
we're watching Jonathan Carl a live
picture of the motorcade carrying Donald
Trump and as John just reported Santucci
there a moment ago the former president
alone with his secrets Service agents on
the way down this is not typical for the
former president who's usually
surrounded by a small team that truly
supports him
yeah an incredible moment this is a guy
who's been the subject of countless
criminal investigations so I think the
important takeaways here there's a
couple of them one is I do want people
to remember that this really may be one
of the first of many indictments there
were already reports and they got
completely lost in the chaos of what has
happened over the last 24 hours there
are already reports that the next
indictment out of Georgia could come at
the end of April this month we may be
under a month away from the next arrest
and indictment so there are many
different questions of course is any of
this going to lead to prison time I
continue to believe that the answer is
absolutely not absolutely not but that
being said we are still at the very
beginning of this still at the very
beginning personally I think the Georgia
one has significant potential
significant potential in terms of
liability this feed is getting a little
bit glitchy sort of like when Trump does
speeches so we'll switch over to the ABC
speech this is uh okay this is the
Manhattan Bridge right
and the next would be Brooklyn as we go
south on FDR what exit are we at
oh no okay so that we are down we're
down in lower Manhattan Brooklyn Bridge
getting off
uh are they pulling off here at exit two
it looks like they are going to
I hope the police isn't driving in the
exit only lane and they're gonna stay on
FDR that would just that is infuriating
when you see that it really is
okay they are pulling off at the
Brooklyn Bridge exit
and then they will loop around many of
uh
many Brooklyn folks know what happens uh
the loop here that exists to get you on
the Brooklyn Bridge over to Brooklyn
that is not the path that they are
taking here not at all the path that
they are taking actually getting off you
see the Brooklyn Bridge in the top left
there
heading east over the river
very very powerful elements here one
thousand people arrested many of them
have been getting significant prison
terms and they believe that it's in a
message of deterrence they're convinced
that's a significant deterrent
particularly after what the country saw
what the world saw and then the
punishment that followed even though
it's taken many months it is indeed
punished prompt punished prompt when he
arrives at the courthouse we have all
sorts of different shots this is a live
shot at the courthouse and Trump just
moments away at this point moments away
Newsmax is of course titillated by the
entire thing and it looks as though they
are really getting ready for his arrival
here we'll continue to follow the
motorcade for now I think
and very very soon they will be at the
courthouse this is Donald Trump in full
makeup stage makeup as he leaves Trump
Tower just moments ago and soon we'll be
arriving uh unclear ah there is the
motorcade they did not stop at any
restaurants or fast food of any kind on
the way in unclear whether there will be
refreshments and snacks the report is
Trump will not be handcuffed he will not
be mugshotted but he will be
fingerprinted and this is truly a
historic day to everybody that is here
with us this is not the likes of which
anything has been seen before many such
examples do not exist do not exist and I
hope that that's clear to everybody and
as you can see here ladies and gentlemen
there are literally
dozens of people out
some of whom presumably support Trump
and some of whom don't uh it is an
historic day well said well said I do
want to say thank you to the
456-78910 additional folks who just
grabbed memberships on my website folks
this is this is it this is the day of
indicted and as you can see the coupon
code is indicted if you're watching on
Twitch YouTube or Facebook we will be
covering all of it all of it let's see
if there is any better shot here it
looks as though I really don't know who
will give us the best shot a lot of uh a
lot of action here ah the overhead
probably is this prompt right here this
seems to be Trump yep there he is
uh is he wearing a white hat or is that
his hair I can't tell Trump walking
walking walking
walking around surrounded by various
Vehicles sort of lumbering Trump of
course Very credibly six foot three and
239 as we all know and we believe and
there he is entering the courtroom Trump
entering the courtroom not he would
speak even if sorry the court the court
uh building the courthouse of course we
will bring that to you uh if and when
that happens otherwise we'll just take
you right through the proceedings here
this morning and Kate Shaw a question I
know a lot of people at home are going
to have does this preclude in any way
this indictment or even this notion of
the potential uh conviction that could
come or not if this is thrown out along
the way there's this in any way preclude
him from running for president and and
even winning in 2024. in a word David no
nothing in the Constitution nothing in
the law prevents an individual under
indictment or even under sentence from
running for president or even serving
for president you know there might of
course be logistical obstacles that all
right folks if you're just joining us
Donald Trump has made it to the
courthouse in lower Manhattan he he is
scheduled to be arraigned in 50 minutes
the process that we believe will be
taking place is that Trump surrounded by
Secret Service agents
within I guess we would say a circle of
Court officers will be fingerprinted
reportedly not
uh mugshotted and reportedly not
handcuffed we can now say and this is a
matter is this diaper going to be
changed I saw that uh this is now a
matter of minutes but the former
president of the United States is now
under arrest under arrest and Secret
Service will now take a sort of
secondary role Trump being followed by a
small number of Secret Service agents
into the courthouse and many will wait
outside in what is just an extraordinary
thing to see an extraordinary thing to
see I do want to say thank you to the
additional seven people who just went to
my website and signed up with the coupon
code indicted ladies and gentlemen if
you're just joining us I I know this is
a day that tens of thousands of you in
my audience have been waiting for for a
very long time and for those who want to
celebrate it by supporting Independent
Media you can go to my website
joinpakman.com
and use the code indicted to get a
discount now if you spell it indicated
the way Trump did on Troth Central the
code actually won't work you do need to
spell it as indicted it's a very very
important thing and that is something we
are going to continue monitoring very
closely how long is this expected to
take my belief is that the arraignment
itself which will likely go on time
because that they're going to be
clearing the courtroom for prompt may
only last 10 minutes and it is scheduled
for 2 15 which is about 45 minutes from
now this should not be very long is
Trump going to make a statement when he
exits it is expected that he wants to
but it is unclear whether he is actually
going to be you know sort of allowed to
uh by his lawyers and of course his
lawyers do have relatively little
control over him in most cases is it
possible that he has sort of been scared
straight into listening to his lawyers
as a result of this criminal situation
it's certainly possible
it's certainly possible but I don't know
that for sure and so we will see Trump
expected to hold a press conference
tonight at Mar-A-Lago and that will be
very very interesting to see as well
let's take a look at what we have over
on Fox News
Fox News seems to constantly be in
commercials I don't get what's going on
see if we can get a look at this
very odd
oh here we go let's listen to what's
happening on Fox news wow they're going
to arrest me I believe this is happening
in America
during this arraymentar
oh well the the term Trump gag order
seems a contradiction of uh in terms I
mean the uh the idea that you could
succeed in gagging the former president
uh
all right look what Santa Fe has oh my
God we just got to get out that's such a
toxic feed I just can't do it all right
ABC News is covering this we are
overhead at the courthouse Trump is
inside this is the view just outside the
courthouse we also have
uh oh okay let's see what's going on
here Horsemen who worked there and they
they do this type of work they
investigate and they they are well
equipped and know how to had a problem
but it's interesting you're saying his
attorneys are likely not with him at
this time during this process that is
correct yes a very lonely feeling well I
was going to say you know listen how
often ladies and gentlemen Donald Trump
is now under arrest it is not a dream do
not adjust your television do not cancel
your subscription to cable news or
whatever wherever it is that you're
watching this Donald Trump is under
arrest and I know that there are so many
people in the chat
who never believed that this would
happen but the failed former president
is now under arrest super chats are
coming in David thanks for the coverage
will they get an official record of his
height and weight I tweeted that earlier
I tweeted that earlier the sound of the
police that is the sound of the Beast
whoop whoop that is the sound of the
police okay so we have songs coming in
do you think they'll be serving warm
food around noon I don't think Trump is
getting snacks today ladies and
gentlemen I don't believe that Trump is
getting snacks let's listen to some of
the voicemails that are coming in hi
David since apparently you don't have a
soul does that mean you can get an
abortion oh God I don't know anything
about that uh let's see what else we
have if anybody else is leaving
voicemails here
um
oh let's see here was
hey Dave
I don't know if been to uh right-wing
media on radio talk show but they are
blue either epic Minds today I have not
yet reviewed I just haven't been able to
follow all of right wing media today I'm
sure they are losing their minds but I I
will have time to catch up on it don't
worry thanks to Michael lemus for
gifting 20 subscriptions via YouTube
putting us at 113 if you are well no not
1100. if you're just joining us the code
is indicted Donald Trump has been
arrested Donald Trump has been arrested
I want to say thank you to eight
additional people who just signed up on
my website with the code indicted let's
review while we have time here some of
the other things that took place today
at the protests and at the entire thing
here is Marjorie Taylor Green in New
York City comparing Trump to Jesus Jesus
was arrested and murdered by the Roman
government there have been many people
throughout history that have been
arrested and persecuted by radical
corrupt governments and it's beginning
today in New York City
um and I just can't believe it's
happening but I'll always support him
he's done nothing wrong he's done
everything right there you go she hasn't
seen the evidence nor the charges but
she knows Trump is completely innocent
hey by the way someone wrote to me and
said Marjorie Taylor green is actually
dating this guy this right side
broadcasting guy is are any of those
people in the chat and is that true that
would be pretty funny actually
anybody know about that she's dating
this this is her this is her partner
right now
a lot of people are saying probably and
some people are saying yes
that's hilarious that is that is
genuinely really really funny
um let's see what else we have if we
have any video from outside the protest
here is uh Marjorie Taylor green trying
to deliver a statement
s
loud noises are now assault
trying to prevent violence
wow as you can see absolute and complete
chaos here's another Marjorie Taylor
green element president Trump is joining
some of the most incredible people in
history being arrested today
now it's good it's good now it's good
that he got arrested um Nelson Mandela
was arrested serve time in prison
oh that is too much I can't even do it I
don't I don't even think I can do it I
don't even think I can do it or people
tell me look at an Aaron rupar tweet
rupar twitter
let's see what he tweeted oh my God
let's see
Jonathan Turley wonders there it is
I'm not seeing what I'm supposed to be
looking at from Aaron rupar
yeah I don't I don't know listen Jesus
Jesus was arrested and murdered by the
Roman government all right anyway so I
guess Trump now is like uh
like Nelson Mandela I guess now they're
saying which is really really wacky
stuff
um okay we are continuing to follow this
Donald Trump is indeed under arrest
let's just see if we have any other new
things that have come forward
since the stream started and this feed
there is Trump entering
the courthouse we saw that already
this is quite an image ladies and
gentlemen this is quite an image Donald
Trump under arrest under arrest
wow
uh Trump posting heading to lower
Manhattan the courthouse seems so
surreal wow they are going to arrest me
can't believe this is happening in
America Maga
that is just delightful
that is just delightful and I think it's
worth taking a pause for a moment and
recognizing the moment that we're in
that we've never been in before
and that is that when he walked into
that Courthouse
and he was escorted officially
Donald Trump
former president of the United States
front runner for the Republican
nomination for president of the United
States is now under arrest and God bless
the United States
we've never seen it before it is a
sobering moment
and even though he's very consistent
ing out social media posts from the car
saying again seems so surreal wow they
are going to arrest me
can't believe this is happening in
America
you could shorten that and say that for
Donald Trump perhaps he can't believe
this is happening right he did not
believe certainly in this case from the
reporting from inside that this was
going to happen and it has now happened
Donald J Trump is under arrest and wow
it has such a nice ring to it it has
such an they've arrested someone who did
Terrible Things terrible terrible things
and uh that is really something else you
know uh all right let's continue looking
at some of these super chats as we stand
by Donald Trump already inside and not
expected to last too long big thanks to
Larry for gifting five subscriptions via
YouTube big thanks to Uncle brat for
gifting 20 putting us at 155 uh thanks
to Holy Earth David keep up the good
work
maybe change your discount code to
arrested indicted is actually powerful I
think Jamal Bowman shouting at Marjorie
Taylor green get the hell out of here is
the best rant ever did you play yeah we
played it earlier it's it's really
something
is Karen Rogers in New York consoling
his red hat buddy very good question
David Hitler was arrested as well a
hundred years ago
is that true
that I don't even know about that's
interesting all right we are continuing
to follow everything that's going on
here do we want to check in on Newsmax
just to see what they're saying they've
been jawing back and forth back and
forth but uh it really hasn't
interrupted into any uh violence
hopefully that maintains yeah in a crowd
that size and what we've seen is there's
usually troublemakers sometimes
pretending to be the other side in both
crowds we we know that the New York City
Police Department is highly professional
oh yeah they're perfectly capable of
handling something like this and
according to my car they're doing a
great job at this moment right now as
Donald Trump is inside the Manhattan
Courthouse it's inside outside of our
view we're hearing he's on the seventh
floor where he is being processed again
moments ago he surrendered and entered
the building so again he's on this what
a day what a day here's right side
broadcasting now I do have an eye on
this so if anything breaking happens I
will make sure we cover that as well but
another great point and Jason Miller has
done a wonderful job of really touching
base on this and nailing it home but
present time because if they can do this
to president Trump they can do this to
any average American they can we
actually already knew that it's so funny
when they say if they can do this to
Trump they can do it to anyone we
already knew they could do it to anyone
anyone can get arrested and charged with
crimes the question is was Trump Above
the Law they're acting like it's
terrible if they do this to Trump they
could do it to anyone no no no
the fact that they can do it to Trump
means he's not above the law that's a
good thing that's a good thing
uh these people really have some sick
sense of uh what what Justice actually
means super chats continue to dump in an
apology over here for something I don't
remember what it is it's okay go David
Trump a clown act Mr orange man exactly
Will trump turn on his supporters for
not saving him finally Trump has been
indicted David sir when does the full
list of charges get released any moment
any moment it is expected that the
indictment will leak let's see
indictment to be revealed imminently
Alvin Bragg press conference later Trump
press conference even later than that
okay since the last since the day I
retired from the Army at 11AM on January
20th 2017.
I dreamed of this day I wouldn't serve a
single minute under him a criminal wow
very strong statement from the uh from
the jackal The Jackal with a very
powerful declaration thanks to carlio
for the twitch Prime subscription really
appreciate that if you're just joining
us you have missed Donald Trump's
motorcade making its way to New York
Criminal Court where Donald Trump is now
under arrest the failed former president
is now under arrest
34 felony counts believed to be in the
indictment which is imminently going to
be released and leaked imminently
absolutely any second this might happen
the situation outside of the New York
Criminal Court you have Secret Service
you have the court officers and you have
NYPD everything it is all happening it
is all happening Donald Trump later
tonight expected to give a press
conference at Mar-A-Lago I can only
imagine how insane and unhinged tonight
is going to be and I may be live
streaming we have a goal of 250 website
members if we hit that I will do another
stream tonight I think we're going to
honestly one two three four five six
seven additional people just signed up
on my website putting us at 164. the
code is indicted my friends and it is
all all happening very very quickly
let's listen to a couple other
voicemails that came in about Trump's
arrest hey David uh this is sunny
um calling from the Florida Georgia area
um
you know love to watch your show uh big
fan I'm a subscriber
um so I'm just wondering you know why no
handcuffs and why no mug shot
[Music]
um
just special treatment for Trump that's
all that's really it
where'd he go there's more to this
voicemail
okay I guess the voicemail ends there
yeah just uh just just special treatment
hmm
one more voicemail yeah man I've been
praying for this day so the fact you say
thoughts and prayers don't worry hey
maybe they do work well they're uh
they're praying against me on the
opposite side but maybe my prayers were
stronger and that's why uh he's being
thrown at you who knows it's possible
you know the reason that this is all
happening it is possible that there were
lots of magas praying Trump wouldn't be
arrested but this caller might have
prayed harder
and maybe that's why I I honestly
couldn't tell you I really couldn't tell
you why this is happening maybe because
the facts point to Trump should be
arrested that it might be that simple
okay other super chats
I was in Middle School when he became
president since then I spent the huge
chunk of my childhood watching the world
go mad sanity is back says Cheshire the
cat
Trump can finally have an outfit that
will match his skin color wow Adam
that is solid very very solid no list of
charges yet I think Vivek
prophesied this says Paul Edwards yeah
[Music]
David sir Will trump see massive dumps
happen in jail I have no idea
I have no idea
remember how the right lost their minds
because of your tweet I can only imagine
how they must be fuming right now
imagine with the Georgia case yeah the
right is very angry with me very very
angry with me Trump is being processed I
see people coming in saying what is
happening Trump is being processed
that's what's happening let's listen to
a little bit of the coverage here from
ABC actually in fact I'm going to step
away for five and refill my water and
we'll listen to this and then I'll be
back and then Trump expected to leave in
about 30 minutes his public speaking as
Donald Trump has been his lawyers have
always had trouble managing that
managing him but he he has to handle
both lines of of his life right now the
fact that he's facing criminal
indictment and this and perhaps future
cases and the fact that millions of
Americans remember 74 million people
voted for him they want him to be
president again there's just been
nothing like it
Terry Moran with us here this afternoon
and Terry as you know our team has been
reporting that he faces the former
president at least at least two dozen
separate counts here in this case this
indictment remains sealed perhaps until
any moment now how long will it take for
the the judge and in that courtroom to
go over each one of these counts before
we see the former president again and
not long before the rest of us know
what's inside this indictment
well we're told of course in Aaron
kutursky has been reporting this that
that it will be probably within minutes
It'll be emailed out as soon as it is
presented to the defendant and that's
the judge's job the judge's job right
now is to make sure that Donald Trump as
he faces these very serious felony
charges in the state of New York
understands them understands his right
rights and understands the process going
forward that that will take some time
he's not going to let him you know get
out of the courtroom until the judge is
certain that there's no reason for
appeal out of this stage he's got to
make sure that all the defendants rights
are protected and that that Donald Trump
goes forward from this courtroom
understanding what he's up against in
court Terry Moran with us from
Washington uh this afternoon Terry thank
you stick with us here we're looking
live right now uh at that hallway on the
15th floor I had mentioned earlier that
this is one of the few areas inside
Criminal Court where there is a
television camera and this is the feed
coming out of that hallway unclear
whether or not the former president has
been brought to the floor as of yet or
whether they are awaiting his arrival
there you see all right this is great
this is a great shot from inside the
courthouse it is completely conceivable
that Donald Donald Trump will issue some
statement either shortly before being
brought in or shortly after this is
where it is all happening it is all
happening at any moment Trump could be
brought through here when the former
president arrives it's our understanding
that again they're waiting for him that
he's undergoing processing uh in a
different part of the building and Aaron
kutursky he has officially surrendered
as any criminal defendant would inside
the building and again as we look at
this live picture Aaron we now await the
former president being brought upstairs
in that elevator that is usually
reserved for judges is this great is it
isn't this just fantastic welcome
everybody I know that there are some
magas here and they are absolutely
Furious but this is a good thing when
there is reason to believe a crime has
been committed and a grand jury says yes
this is what happens this is called Law
and Order whatever they think of as Law
and Order it's not this if you care
about Law and Order yeah well you know
whatever law uh I just saved a bunch on
my car insurance as well so it is all
happening
um if you yes okay so
listen it's likely I will stream the
Mar-A-Lago press conference tonight
which will be insane we're still 75
members and twitch subscribers away from
250. I think we're gonna get there
honestly and that stream would start at
7 45 and if you're watching on YouTube
right now make sure you're subscribed to
the YouTube channel or if you're you
know watching on Twitch make sure you
follow you'll then get notified when we
go live if and when we go live tonight
but I do expect that that would happen
just because of the rate at which people
are signing up for memberships there's
another five just dumped in puts us at
180 and a lot of excitement this very
much resonating thanks to crap storm for
the subscription on Twitch uh our great
friend s Perez was in there gifting some
stuff uh and it's uh it is a very very
very busy day the schedule I know a lot
of people are rolling in and out very
very quickly the schedule is as far
Donald Trump is currently under arrest
he has indeed surrendered already he is
being processed and momentarily he will
be arraigned at which point the charges
will be read we don't yet have the
indictment but Yahoo news is able to
exclusively report that it is 34
felonies they started with one
misdemeanor give me a break
and then it went to well 34 misdemeanors
but no felonies and then it went to 34
misdemeanors but only one felony and the
latest report is 34 felony counts 34
felony counts I am monitoring the
indictment has not yet been released as
far as I can tell
as far as I can tell but it probably
will within moments of the 2 15 PM
Eastern arraignment Donald Trump will
then leave we will probably see it here
at that point he may make a statement
it's not clear he will then fly back to
Mar-A-Lago where he will hold a press
conference tonight that I will
potentially cover that I will
potentially cover
um welcome to everybody who is just
joining that is where we are right now
we did see the motorcade arrive earlier
and
um it has been about do people remember
how long ago the motorcade arrived
actually let's take a look here
I guess it was about
20 minutes ago roughly uh
no actually it was more like
25 minutes ago okay so Trump's been here
already about 25 minutes and
um this is inside We Believe on either
the 7th or 15th floor Caitlin Collins is
in there that is where he is going to be
arranged before the judge got it in a
few moments all right Caitlin thank you
stand by uh here with John Miller
um and uh and and Karen uh agnifilo also
Ellie honig
explain the 15th floor saying he's on
the seventh floor right now John you
read the question of his Miranda rights
Karen is he given his Miranda rights he
probably will be just to remind him not
to say anything not to blurt anything
out and just in case he does say
anything the prosecutors will want to
use that potentially at trial he would
want to have made sure that his Miranda
warnings are red because it's it the
Miranda warnings are triggered not just
from an arrest but if you're in in
custody and you're being interrogated
and being asked questions so they'd want
to be very technical and buy the book
that's going to be an extraordinary
moment for former president United
States to have
court officer a former detective or
current detective to work at the DA's
office reading his Miranda rights to him
has got to be kind of an out-of-body
experience for the investigator to say
Mr President you have the right to
remain silent you have the right to an
attorney the legal complication here is
uh there's there's a there's a couple of
rules that laws in play here he's
represented by Council the DA's office
understands that and they're not allowed
to question him but Karen raises the
point if he starts talking as Donald
Trump is sometimes want to do and making
spontaneous statements if one of them is
relevant I like that phrase it was a
spontaneous statement you mean he
blurted out some nonsense statements
during booking to get used against them
at trial constantly and this is another
moment if he has been read his Miranda
rights you have the right to remain
silent that is another reality hit that
is another sobering moment the other
thing I should add is right about now is
the time when the defense lawyers would
be given the indictment because they
need to go through it in advance because
what will happen in the actual courtroom
is the judge will ask the defendant and
the defenseless have you had a chance to
go through this indictment because they
have to know what's in it before they
can plead and then the judge will say
would you like me to read it to you
publicly or do you waive the public
reading do you give up the public
reading ninety percent of the time maybe
more than that the defendant says we
wave it we don't need you to read it out
loud publicly we've got reportedly 30
plus counts here I imagine they will
waive it maybe they want to stand on
ceremony and have every single one of
those 30 plus counts read but right
about now it should be in their hands
the court it was supposed to be 215
correct yes uh it's supposed to be 2 15.
now is that something they would move up
depending on how fast the processing
goes or is 215 the the time the court
the courts take a break for lunch every
day from one o'clock to 2 15. that is
one of those things that is just
so you think sounds pretty good
because these guys didn't get to eat if
that's true but I I think the other
thing is this is there is nothing normal
that's the final indignity that they're
on a lunch break if that's the case
that's the port Securities but this this
is it sir everybody's on lunch break
you're gonna have to hold here quickly
close down as of one o'clock everybody
had to be out so if there was a trial
going on anything else they're running a
couple of arraignment Parts downstairs
but you know all right so as you can see
we are very very much anxiously awaiting
the appearance of trump here uh in the
courtroom soon scheduled for a 2 15 PM
arraignment and it really really really
is an extraordinary situation we are all
witnessing history and it is so great to
have everybody here I do have free
memberships available tons of them are
being gifted if you would like a free
membership please go to davidpackman.com
free
membership slash free membership we are
going to have time to review everything
the chaos outside the courthouse the
protests Marjorie Taylor Green's
presence there there are so many
different things to discuss one of the
elements we are waiting for is the
actual indictment believed to contain 34
felony counts 34 felony counts and that
will be made available we would imagine
pretty soon after pretty soon after the
arraignment scheduled for just 20 uh 21
minutes from now scheduled for 21
minutes from now do they have elements
of bathrooms available for Trump I'm
sure they do
I'm sure they do I don't know why they I
don't know why they wouldn't voicemails
and super chats are pouring in Dan Mann
says they better watch and make sure he
doesn't mule sensitive documents out do
a full cavity search
sounds aggressive could it be possible
this will all backfire and get worse or
is Trump done how high is the chance as
I've said before I think that this
indictment helps Trump in the primary
and hurts him in the general
if there are more indictments my
perspective on that may change
uncharged pickles Subway pizza lunch is
vital eat fresh yeah it looks like some
people might have had to miss lunch for
this you know Quasimodo predicated all
this Donald Trump never had the makings
of a varsity athlete
huh
hey David historic day so happy to see
it also have you heard of rational Wiki
yeah I've heard of rational Wiki
um we've got a couple voicemails coming
in
let's see what else we have
what else do we have here a lot of these
actually don't really seem to have to do
with the indictment
and we're really doing indictment stuff
hey David catdad here
um I woke up this morning in my
my cat came up to me tears in his eyes
and said sir
I don't need my treats this morning the
the greatest treat has you know come
full circle and we're witnessing it now
tears pouring from my cat's eyes I might
I might need to take him uh money take
him into the Vet but uh anyways keep up
good work David me and my cat love you
take care thank you very very much
appreciate that wow wow wow wow what a
day what a day
hey David Melody from Missouri again
here
um I just want to know who do you think
there's going to start blaming after
George Soros does pass away probably in
the next several years just a question
thank you well they seem to be latching
on to Klaus Schwab now a lot replacing
one old Jewish guy with another Jewish
guy so I think it's possible that it'll
be um Klaus Schwab or maybe the ghost of
George Soros I think could be it
um yeah
who knows
David I'm calling to you with tears just
flowing streaming from my eyes as a
proud uh this is a wonderful
day this should be a new like national
holiday or something like that uh love
your show
uh keep up the good work all right very
good well a lot of people coming in a
lot of people crying too
sir I come to you and keep in mind I'm a
pretty big birdie guy I mean I'm a
pretty big Burly guy and I come to you
with tears in my eyes thanking you for
all you've done
just wiping my tears away
have a great day
sir wow very polite audience today
people seemingly really buttoned up and
ready for uh what what is an incredible
incredible situation here
um big thank you to everybody watching
on Twitch uh I have not forgotten about
twitch we love everybody on Twitch we're
standing by here in the courtroom let's
listen to the latest involve this uh
Federal campaign or election law
violation the pro the Manhattan DA's
office cannot prosecute that crime it's
a federal offense so they couldn't
articulate that as a conspiracy to
commit that crime because it's not a
state crime and so it makes you wonder
is there another Financial crime for
example they could do this through a
scheme okay I am being told that the
website has crashed I'm gonna tell you
why it is
286 people right now are trying to sign
up for a membership okay so let's listen
to this I'm going to reset the website
right now it won't take long just
picking up on what Adam said a
conspiracy charge it could also be an
agreement with David pecker for example
it doesn't necessarily only have to be a
conspiracy with Michael Cohen and it's
going to be for a period of time so from
honor about a period of time to honor
about a period of time and it allows
much more evidence to come in that a
judge might otherwise hold out because
it's saying it's not related to these
did you make this business record entry
and conspiracies also all right
everybody any moment we will see
something here we are rebooting the
website the website is under very heavy
load from people trying to sign up for
memberships a lot of things are
happening at once here we're doing our
best to manage everything we can
everything we can this is now we are in
the last 15 minutes before this
arraignment is scheduled standby
together to agree to pay hush money
payments did they how are they going to
influence the election things that
aren't necessarily elements of a crime
or a crime obviously the doors opened a
number of people
it's the da staff that's the D.A staff
what does that tell you about
Sue hoffinger Peter Pope we're there I
couldn't see everyone but I see some
Financial crimes analysts going in whoa
so it looks like it's the team that
worked on this indictment so where are
they coming from and where are they
going to are they going to the courtroom
they're going in the courtroom yeah okay
so the court so that's the door that the
president Karen that's the door the
president former president is likely to
come through and the courtroom is
immediately to the left so there are
many doors into the courtroom and it's
not just this one door there are side
doors and there's a back door you're not
just speaking metaphorically so there
are many doors in the courtroom and many
hallways that lead to each door
depending on where someone's coming from
a judge comes in a different door a jury
comes in even another door a defendant
who's incarcerated comes in a different
door the public comes in the main door
so there are many doors to choose from
depending on for security reasons which
way they decided uh Mr Trump should go
just this one one thing I was just
thinking about right here is the irony
of the situation all those all those
rallies where they mag a crowd chanted
all right folks website is back up
website is back up we're deploying
additional resources the the website uh
taking shots left and right ad
well same time one other interesting
point is in a criminal case unlike a
civil case that Mr Trump will have to
make the court appearances each one so
he will have to keep coming back to this
court to face this judge oh what a
pleasure that's going to be it's for
every time that the the case gets
adjourned whether it's for a hearing or
for for a status conference or for a
trial so he this is this is a doors he
will be watching folks asking if the
judge is a woman and whether Trump will
be triggered by that no but the judge is
Hispanic and uh I mean listen
I think we all know how that's going to
go based on how it went with that
Mexican-American judge related to the
travel ban years ago security uh as as
Adam said and there there were the D.A
staff that went into the courtroom and
they're going to go sit at the district
attorney table in the well which is
where the the courtroom uh where the
where the judge sits and where the
lawyers sit and where the jury boxes and
where Witnesses sit uh there's there's a
there's a bar that then separates that
from the public in the well which is
what that area is called there will be
at least two tables one for the
prosecutors and their staff and then one
for Mr Trump and his lawyers there will
also be room for the Secret Service and
the court officers and the court clerks
will be there will be a court clerk who
will be sitting behind a desk and that
is the person who will arraign Mr Trump
and he will he will be given an
indictment number right so they will say
calling docket or sorry indictment
number one two three four five which
will be calendar number one today on the
calendar uh the people of the state
they'll announce who the charges are
against President Donald J Trump the
clerk will read him the indictment the
charges he will arraign him on the
charges and ask him Mr Trump how do you
plead and he was guilty or not guilty he
said he will plead not guilty and the
next thing that happens is the the judge
asks the prosecutor whether they have
any anything they want to file with the
defendant and serve on the court those
could be oral oral notifications that
they file or written filings that they
can do and is there any other is there
any other information that that the
prosecution wants to give they also give
it to the uh to the defense attorney and
all right welcome everybody who is just
coming in let me catch you up on
everything that is going on the former
president has been arrested he showed up
in court about 35 minutes ago he is
currently being processed no mug shot
yes fingerprints no handcuffs from what
we have seen we are now standing by near
a courtroom we have just seen
investigators of financial crimes enter
the court Trump's arraignment is
scheduled for only 12 minutes from now
12 minutes from now we may see Trump
walk in momentarily the arraignment is
expected to be quite short Trump is then
expected to maybe make a statement
afterwards fly back to Florida where
tonight he will hold a press conference
which I may be covering live that's
where we are right now I want to say
thanks to three additional people who
just signed up on my website putting us
at 227 if this gets to 250 we're doing
the next live stream tonight with the
press conference and I I do think it's
probably going to be
quite Bonkers any moment Trump expected
in let's look at some super chats
David I must admit I've had a huge crush
on you for years your intelligence is
very sexy unfortunately I must respect
my love Josh's wishes and not slide into
your DMs anymore wow that's an
incredible thing was not aware of that
but I will I will have to look for it a
thanks to Jill
and The Alchemist
if Trump were going to submit an
insanity plea would that be now or later
I believe lawyers please tell me if you
plan to do Insanity you would do not
guilty now and then not guilty by reason
of insanity later is that is my
assessment correct on that lawyers in
the chat anybody
yeah we know he's not insane and he's
just a narcissist I'm I'm just
just to actually ask the question
they would wait for pre-trial okay
all right very good
I lost many white male friends to the
far right this is just this whoa David
keep up the great work this is just the
start of the Fall I'm very concerned
with what's going on in Tennessee we
need to Pivot to that and call it out
yes in fact the top story on today's
podcast is about Tennessee big thank you
to three additional people who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code indite
and two more as well putting us at 232
will we be locked in for another stream
tonight
for folks emailing me about the free
memberships do not email me go to
davidpackman.com free membership now
here's the thing
uh do not go to davidpackman.com go to
davidpackman.com free membership and
everything you need to know will be made
available there
all right very very powerful is this
actor Kevin James in the middle
with a beard is it possible that that's
who that is
very very interesting all right it looks
like things are happening
Kevin James is signaling people
yeah it seems like we are moments away
from something and what that is is hard
to tell being made today a lot of
questions about whether Alvin Bragg will
uh present what's called a speaking
indictment essentially lay out the story
lay out the case that the district
attorney is trying to make here and is
there any question in your mind Kate and
Dan whether or not this will be a
speaking indictment you know I presume
that office you know has largely shifted
to speaking indictments particularly in
a case like this so I expect we're going
to see a good amount of detail narrative
not just this sort of bare bones kind of
bullet point charges I certainly hope so
because we are all hoping and viewers
are all hoping to get a real sense of
what the case will look like when the
D.A puts it on and so I have to imagine
that's informing the decision so I do
expect to speak I think I think that in
conjunction with the fact that he's
already announced he's going to have a
press conference afterwards tells you
that there's going to be information in
there I mean this is not going to be the
sort of thing where he's just going to
say okay you know this is the legal
charges Etc and we're not going to
discuss it beyond that he's going to
hold a press conference I'd expect
there's going to be detail in the
indictment as well that will explain
exactly what they think that the
president did why it's a violation of
the law
Etc and that's the key right it's not
just the law it's the facts and how the
how the facts relate to the law and
that's what is speaking segment really
does is it doesn't just say a violation
of this particular law and here's the
definition of law it explains why the
facts in this case show that there was a
violation he knows full well this
district attorney that he is now you
know
Target number one oh absolutely
politically at least from the
Republicans yeah it's not just
politically Alvin Bragg now
um with quite heavy security when he
moves around in New York City
uh we are moments away from the start of
this uh arraignment David can you
provide context for the Maga trollers
the difference between the steel dossier
versus Trump's potential campaign
Finance violations with hush money yeah
I I can those things don't have anything
to do with each other so let me not do
that right now
but we can certainly do that
obligatory reminder for Illinois and
Wisconsin residents to vote today
Count Me In as one of the people that
realized they couldn't live without you
after the April Fool's video I finally
signed up on the website thank you very
much so we lost the feed it looks as
though something is happening here
they are clearing the hallway a lot of
action you know perhaps the judge is
signaling we're going to do things the
way we had scheduled to do things here
Aaron kutursky just outside uh that
building in lower Manhattan Criminal
Court and Aaron I know you are watching
this out of the monitor uh right here
with the rest of us again tell us what's
uh playing out here inside this building
what will they have had to have done
ladies and gentlemen I'm told the
website is back up and holding the
website is up and holding soon to crash
again I'm sure we are moments away from
the arraignment of Donald Trump it is
getting increasingly frenetic there's a
frenetic energy here in the courtroom in
the courthouse just outside the
courtroom looks like a combination of
NYPD Court officers Secret Service and
miscellaneous security the uh
arraignment not expected to be not
expected to be very long customarily any
new Criminal Case is accompanied by
fingerprints so it's likely that the
former president's prints were taken
we've seen a couple of members of the
DA's Squad of those of the individuals
to actually deal with the defendant
personally and I can see them going in
and out of that area that that blackened
door where behind which is the elevator
the the former president will ride I see
there the chief of the court security
officers and the uh cropped white hair
and in the white shirt and all of this
movement indicates that the former
president's arrival in court there on
the 15th floor is imminent the gentleman
right in the middle in the purple tie is
um one of the spokesmen for the office
of Court Administration who helped
coordinate some of the former
president's movements and there is
district attorney Alvin Bragg wow
has just been brought up the elevator as
well and entered the courtroom under
heavy guard wow David the Manhattan D.A
has endured a number of attacks
including a white powder that was sent
to his office along with a death threat
that said Alvin I'm going to kill you
ever since then he has been under
immediate protection his security detail
has been expanded so has the security
around some of the key prosecutors
involved in this case and you could see
him there entering Port under the
protection of officers David no question
Aaron thank you a clear sign that this
is about to get underway we have just
seen the Manhattan district attorney
Alvin Bragg enter the courtroom on the
15th floor of the Criminal Court in
lower Manhattan and as Aaron mentioned
under uh heavy heavy security not only
to protect the former president but to
protect it as a D.A who has taken the
incoming criticism
very heated criticism in recent days not
only from it does look like they are
running on time this is scheduled for 4
four minutes from now the D.A is already
in the courtroom investigators are
already in the courtroom there's a sort
of a the feeling that something here is
going on and it does appear as though
they are running on time for a 215
arraignment here for this man he's
called him an animal he's gone after him
in deeply personal terms as he's also
attacked the judge this is this is
Donald Trump's style it's always been
his style we know how he went after uh
Robert Mueller and Mueller's
investigations we know after how he went
after the Democrats who let the
impeachment drive both impeachment
drives uh in in the Congress and the
Republicans who joined in that second
drive but now again he's in a criminal
process where he is not in total control
anymore a trained fighter through his
own life experience political and and
business experience leading up to this
moment but again John he's never faced
this kind of fight before yeah and you
know his his mentor
on such matters was the the the former
the lawyer Roy Cohn uh who taught him
that what you do is you fight you fight
you never acknowledge anything okay I'm
seeing confusion in the chat between
tonight's press conference by trumpet
Mar-A-Lago the DA's press conference at
4 pm Eastern and whether Trump will
speak to the media after leaving the
arraignment so let's go through these in
order let's go through these
chronologically the reporting has been
that Trump wants to address the media in
some hallway in this Courthouse when he
leaves whether or not that will happen I
don't know
secondly at 4 pm Eastern the D.A Alvin
Bragg is expected to hold a press
conference outlining the
um charges and then once Trump gets back
to Florida tonight he has scheduled a
press conference for 8 15 PM Eastern
Time 8 15 PM eastern time and that would
be a completely separate thing now
because Matthew and Michael just signed
up on my website putting us at 242. I
believe we are going to get to 250 today
and that that will lock in that second
stream which I will probably start at 7
45 PM eastern time we do not yet have
the indictment the indictment is to be
revealed at this arraignment scheduled
to start one minute from now 34 felony
accounts is the reporting
we need to wait and see what's in there
we just don't know yet we don't know yet
but that is expected to be released very
soon imminently imminently in fact I
would say uh a lot of uh discussion and
chatting and different things going on
here
um
yeah
any moment now expecting Trump I guess
to come through unless they're bringing
him in through some other door there are
many ways to get into that courtroom as
has been reported I do want to say
thanks to five additional folks who just
signed up on my website putting us at
248. we are almost there we are truly
almost there
uh Super Chat coming in it is
unfortunate that not even the Socratic
method would help in order to reason
with these Maga cult followers David do
you think Maga Republicans are a far cry
from the Waco Texas cult that was raided
by ATF some years ago I recently read a
book about the Waco cult book by Jeff
Gwynn released two months ago excellent
book
I do believe that Maga is different than
the Branch Davidians but I do agree that
Maga is extraordinarily cult-like
and you know we could we could explore
the details maybe at a future at a
future moment thank you to the four
additional people who just signed up for
memberships that pushes us over 250 I
will stream the Trump press conference
tonight at Mar-A-Lago let's go for 300
Just for kicks but the stream tonight is
indeed happening and thanks to PC hippie
for the twitch Prime subscription as
well you have not missed anything other
than Trump arriving at the courthouse
and uh he is expected to enter the
courtroom momentarily we are now at the
time it is the stroke of 215 on the East
Coast when the arraignment has been
scheduled and any second it should start
towns and now the question is Donald
Trump heading into court and what is
that about to look like David and until
this moment John had they been given any
hint from the DA's office as to what was
in that indictment or simply nothing
nothing David if anything the
conversations over the last couple days
have been described as pleasant logistic
planning according to my sources and
that is extent of it there has been no
conversation as to what is in this
document if it includes felonies if it
includes misdemeanors there's a lot of
questions now David as to quite frankly
um what this is going to look like and
you know what's Trump's reaction to it a
lot of AIDS have been texting me that
are not there uh bracing you know
waiting to see what his reaction is
going to be as we report it here he's
been polling people over the last couple
days what the what do you think this
could look like Donald Trump's one of
the few people right now that knows
and of course the question are there any
surprises in this indictment we know it
stems from the Stormy Daniels hush money
payment but whether or not the former
president himself will be surprised by
anything they're in
absolutely and I think one of the other
things that we've reported in the last
couple days David is that the DA's
office uh just towards the end
um before the grand jury handed up this
indictment started to present evidence
about another payment made by Donald
Trump to another woman Karen McDougall
that he had a relationship with around
the same time as Stormy Daniels it'll be
curious David uh given the late word we
got that that became part of the
District Attorney's presentation to that
grand jury if there's anything about
that case in this indictment we're
waiting to sing John thank you John
Santucci who has reported on Donald
Trump for years for us I just want to
pause here to listen in on the silence
in this hallway 15th floor criminal yeah
so we are standing by and any moment
this arraignment is set to take place we
are monitoring the scene outside of the
courthouse inside of the courthouse a
lot of different things going on Newsmax
monitoring the feed as well we also have
right side broadcasting which is
covering it it is really garnering the
attention of so many so many as we stand
by and listen if it if this is what we
have been led to believe Trump will
enter through that door in the very back
of the room and then exit into the
courtroom screen right as we look at it
but we also know that there are other
ways to get into the courtroom and maybe
Trump is being brought in a different
way and we're not even going to see him
at all as the video uh is quite choppy
very very choppy video from the
courtroom and always unpredictable these
things are often changed at the last
minute for security or other reasons
everybody's certainly acting like Trump
is about to walk through here but I
don't know that we actually know that to
be the case and we're good we're just
going to have to wait and see a couple
other people have been continuing to
leave voicemails for me David love the
show
a friend of mine came up to me today
tears in his eyes
and he said sir
Donald Trump has been arrested today yep
keep in mind he's a big strong Burly man
tears streaming down his face
behold
oh but seriously you know what cracks me
up
this rhetoric that uh the right wing is
spewing out here with if it could happen
to him it could happen to you
are these people serious do they not
know that that's
something that could easily happen to
them already it's just
mine I mean anyways love the show keep
it up yep thank you very much very much
appreciate that
hi David I'm just sitting here watching
the Trump indictment with you and I just
wanted to let the audience know that
given up the courthouse is in a liberal
New York
um there are reports that Trump is
having to flush 10 to 15 times
so just a crazy situation down there on
the ground and I report this to you with
tears in my eyes Sir very very important
very very important stuff
um let's see what else we have
hi David I'm watching your live coverage
of
the
arrest that's going on right now and um
I couldn't help but think whenever the
helicopter was showing the motorcade
driving the
Sarah your wife is in the air
um
that it's so funny to me but I was just
wondering do you
do you think that
um Roger Stone
is watching this like butthole clinched
okay all right let's
um let's move on
oh man
let's see what else we have here
man that's uh the audience is really
getting getting very very excited
David I just want to let you know um
that last comment you just made about
George soro's future replacement bio
swab is not Jewish really he is not
Jewish and he has no ties to Judaism or
Israel I had no idea about that I
assumed just from the name Schwab I
thought that Klaus Schwab was Jewish now
do the anti-semites think he's Jewish
would sort of be like the next question
uh but that's uh
that's a whole He repeat repeat he is
not Jewish interesting very very
interesting stuff
yo if Trump is convicted of a felony
does that mean legally that we could be
voting for someone who isn't allowed to
vote
uh what's the legal eagle on that thanks
that's interesting I mean it's really a
state question Trump you know in Florida
formerly convicted felons of non-violent
crimes do get to vote again
but the conviction that I don't know the
answer to that question that's a very
interesting question I have to admit I
have to admit that is interesting um and
and that's about it
um but but you know these are the same
officers who are there uh many of them
they've obviously enhanced the number
there who work in these courtrooms every
day who work with the juries every day
and they're just there and doing their
job
they are doing their job we saw a
gentleman in the suit there in the pin
which gives it away the Secret Service
Pierre layers of law enforcement
gathered throughout Manhattan today the
barricades a couple of barricades deep
outside the courthouse outside Trump
Tower that is usually the case though
reinforced obviously knowing that the
former president was coming back to New
York from Mar-A-Lago just the coverage
in the last 24 hours on cable news the
live coverage of his plane taking off
from Florida and then Landing in New
York surreal in nature though
reminiscent of other inflection points
along the way and covering Donald Trump
his political career and now it brings
us here to Criminal Court in lower
Manhattan every time we hear one of
those tones or those bells we wonder is
it the elevator is it some sort of
signal now we do know that they had
always intended to have this arraignment
at about 2 15 Eastern here in New York
we know from Aaron John Catherine's
reporting that the president has been
fingerprinted has been processed booked
like any other criminal defendant
already wow that what's transpired here
in the interim is that the former
president and his legal team have now
been given the indictment it's important
to point out that they also had no hint
you know like the rest of us waiting
today to see what Alvin Bragg uh is
going to present in this courtroom as
far as the indictment against Donald
Trump they have not seen it until today
so this trip up to the 15th floor
uh in this elevator that's been reserved
for the former president will no doubt
include at some point along the way a
moment to read through this indictment
to digest what they will be in that
courtroom to face
and Terry Moran this this notion that
once you walk into a courtroom and
you're before the judge there's nothing
more Stark than that moment when you
realize the judge is now in control wow
absolutely having spent a lot of time in
courtrooms covering trials as Dan did as
well that is an ominous moment for
anyone in the position of Donald Trump
and we should spare a thought right now
for the many many thousands of Americans
who aren't famous who have come within
the grip of the long arm of the law yeah
justly maybe some unjustly Donald Trump
now as well and I always thought
covering trials going into courthouses
around the country that I was lucky to
be a reporter because you always see
people having the worst day of their
lives they're under arrest or their
their family members of those who are
under arrest they're facing just an
ordeal one that they may well have
brought on justly on themselves because
of their conduct but this is a personal
uh drama that that even someone as
defiant and uh who and public is as
strong as Donald Trump has been in the
face of all kinds of impeachments and
civil cases and accusations and getting
cops getting a little bit uh a little
bit bored here checking their checking
their watches we're monitoring all of
these different feeds this is the view
outside of the courthouse we are inside
of the courthouse Newsmax continues to
cover this let's listen a little bit and
it has to be to Europe
it has to be an issue of he had to
willingly or knowingly do what he has
been charged with doing it's not an it's
not an issue of negligence
yeah all right the other thing too is
that the other thing too Bob is that is
look you prosecute people because you
take them can you make it safe for the
community I mean there are all sorts of
different uh prongs for prosecuted
prosecutor makes decisions well one one
reason is for deterrence and that you
make a big splash so that other people
don't do it that's a legitimate reason
to prosecute a case is that all right so
there's Greta Van Susteren and then we
also have
um right side broadcasting is outside
focusing on this crowd and it's hard to
tell if they're protesting in favor of
or against Trump that's the tough thing
this is happening uh because he decided
to run uh back in November I think it's
November 15th when he made that
announcement so um it looks like now
we've got two camera angles for you guys
uh from two different points of view
here on the ground in New York and we're
going to keep this going keep this up
for you guys and keep you guys updated
as we know things uh again he was
scheduled to be arraigned about 10 or 11
minutes ago so at this point we do 100
believe we know he's been in the
courthouse he's been in the courthouse
now for at least half an hour but at
this point he should be in front of the
judge yep so I I guess he's not in front
of the judge in the sense that we
haven't seen that on any of these feeds
which we are monitoring but we will know
all of it and much more I assume very
very soon
um could it really be only a 10-minute
arraignment listen people are talking
about it and saying 10-minute
arraignment
my assumption is it's probably more like
20 to 30 minutes but if there are
lawyers in the chat they might be able
to tell us I mean they might try to keep
this very quick on purpose I don't know
all of the different factors and
priorities that would be at play but you
would think they would try to get it
done and over with relatively quickly
ladies and gentlemen I hope you will
join me tonight after this arraignment
Donald Trump is flying back to
Mar-A-Lago in Florida
and at 8 15 PM Eastern he will be
holding a press conference which I can
only imagine will maybe be the most on
thing unhinged thing he will have ever
done based on the the truths that he's
been posting lately uh all right here's
a bunch more people walking through
looks like things are starting to happen
here A bunch of people coming through uh
I will be live tonight I will be live
tonight
so make sure if you're watching right
now on YouTube that you hit the
Subscribe button it's absolutely free to
do look at these dumps of subscribers
happening on YouTube make sure you hit
subscribe if you're watching on Twitch
make sure you're following you'll be
notified tonight when we go live okay
and then that'll be I'll probably go
assuming it's still 8 15.
uh there is Trump
look at this under arrest the former
president under arrest
and he has now entered the courtroom
that is the former president of the
United States being perp walked with no
handcuffs maybe there's Jason Miller
look at him look following behind like a
puppy dog
um I don't know that there's ever been a
more innocent president of the United
States I really don't folks could be the
most innocent they've ever seen like
we've never such as seen before all
right if you blinked you might have
missed it Donald Trump is now in the
courtroom for his arraignment he looks
scared folks I have never seen Trump
with that look on his face before that
looked like a genuinely
terrified Donald Trump
wow let's just see if we can even find
that exact moment because that was
really something else let's see if we
there look at this I have never seen
Trump look like this before
that looks to me
that is that is that is priceless is
this the mug shot right here
wow
I don't even recognize this Trump
wow there is there's just a different
feeling that even if when he gets back
to Mar-A-Lago he starts you know going
back to much of the rhetoric uh that
he's issued about this D.A Etc when
you're in the courthouse particularly in
a courtroom but even in the courthouse
it's ladies and Gentlemen please
understand
this may be the first of two three or
four arrests and indictments and
arraignments of Donald Trump this may we
may be doing this again and again and
again over the next four to six months
what a moment what a moment an arrested
former president of the United States
incredible that is uh those are a few
seconds of video
that are quite historic quite historic
uh all right let me get caught up on
everything else that's going on here
uh
uh okay website I've been told the
website is working beautifully right now
folks if you're here to celebrate the
indictment of trump the coupon code is
indicted get yourself to join pacman.com
282 people can't possibly be wrong that
also includes people who have supported
on Twitch and I appreciate all of you
all as well the indictment is now in the
arraignment phase here is Donald Trump
looking visibly scared visibly scared
entering the courtroom to be arraigned
on 34 felonies It is believed we are
standing by for the indictment itself it
has not yet leaked but it is expected to
leak or be released very very soon
um and then we will be able to see
exactly what the charges are Donald
Trump will then be leaving the
courthouse he will leave the courtroom
maybe address the media we just don't
know yet we don't know yet whether he
will address the media let's listen to
what is on the minds of so many of the
people that are calling in
it's really been a long uh four five six
seven years however long it's been
um you got me through uh uh the the four
years of trump and along with Stephen
King I mean you guys have such a great
outlook on on uh on him and what we were
actually going through for that entire
four years wow but um have a great day
and uh thanks for uh all these all that
you do thank you very much I appreciate
that
David I think myself and others really
appreciate your indicted coupon code
huge discount on the members only show
but
what if you hadn't indicated I know
coupon code because we have an even
bigger discount thanks David that could
be that could be that that's certainly
something that uh we may need to look
into very very strongly uh let's see
here hello David my wife Megan and I are
making a prison themed dinner for a
party tonight because we've been waiting
for this day so long she's uh busy
flying up the bologna and I'm making the
lumpy mashed potatoes we'd like to know
if you have a particular wine that you
would recommend uh with this prison
dinner yeah I would go with like full
body medium oak red full body medium oak
red probably for that let's listen to
Chris Christie and Dan others is
accurate I'll give you the Lynn site
from the seven years I was U.S attorney
um I was friends with Donald Trump
during those years and he was fascinated
by the cases that I brought and I would
get notes from him on a regular basis on
newspaper clips about indictments that
we had brought or convictions that we
have gotten and he was always very very
interested in what the criminal process
was like
um cheering me on when I would bring
charges against people
um that when I would get convictions and
this was somebody who is not
unacquainted with this process even
though this is his first time as a
defendant he was interested in it he
would ask me lots of questions about it
he had lots of opinions about it and so
I think it's probably a surreal moment
for him that for all the rest of his
life he was doing this as an observer
and today he is the participant he's the
person who's being charged being
fingerprinted and he used to ask about
that process as well how does that work
what happens when they get surrendered
to the FBI so I know that he has thought
a lot about this over the years in the
context of other people but for him to
be going through is today I don't care
what his staff says this is a very very
difficult day for Donald Trump
and Chris what do you make of the fact
that and you know him well that he has
been so successful over the years at
pushing back the law if you will
defending himself delaying uh stalling
and obviously there could be delays
after this day we we fully expect them
as we watch this case unfold but the
fact that he would be booked
fingerprinted brought upstairs to the
15th floor there now and is a criminal
defendant in front of the judge as we
speak
well David look two different contexts
right he's been extraordinarily
successful as Dan had mentioned earlier
on the Civil side of things and and
civil by its very nature is a little
more collegial often a little less
serious
um and a little more prone to delay
um there is a right to a speedy trial in
the Constitution and so prosecutors are
always Under Pressure try to move as
quickly as possible and judges don't let
defendants normally do uh do anything
that creates undue delay
um so I think his normal practice that
he's been successful at on the Civil
side will have much less success on the
criminal side of things we have some but
much about success and in addition what
we're talking about here is something
that he has worked hard his entire life
to avoid by the way he conducts his
business no emails no text messages
um when he speaks to you about business
he speaks in a kind of code language
where you don't always know exactly what
he's saying but you kind of get feeling
for what he's implying he's done all
that because I think Roy Cohn taught him
to do that not to have any paper trail
and so this is going to be interesting
to see what's in the indictment what
documents they have I can guarantee you
this much they're not from Donald Trump
um I never got an email from him in the
22 years I've known him never got a text
message from him in the 22 years I've
known him he just doesn't do it so
fascinating Chris when you describe
those notes on newspaper clippings and
we've heard that anecdote from so many
people who have interacted with Donald
Trump over the years uh I just got to
ask you before I let you go and I know
you're going to be with us throughout
the afternoon here but before we let you
go this time if you think your one-time
friend ever thought that he after
writing those notes to you
congratulating you on indictments
through the years if he would ever find
himself in this position
no I don't think he ever thought he
would because I think he thought he was
too clever to ever wind up in this
situation too close as many narcissists
believe that is exactly right the
situation that's why he wanted to
testify with the Mueller probe and his
lawyers are like are you nuts you're
just gonna lie your head off political
thoughts of well you know I can make
this okay for myself I can fight but
there is also I think the overwhelming
thought going through his mind right now
is how the hell did I get here how did
this happen to me and how am I going to
get out of it
former Governor Chris Christie former
prosecutor himself Chris thank you
always appreciate you the context that
you bring to the conversation I want to
bring back in John Santucci who has been
reporting out inside Trump World these
last 24 hours and John so many people
are asking for this like in this Super
Chat can you change the coupon code to
indicate it here's the deal the real
coupon code is indicted
and that saves you 50 I have also set it
up so if you misspell indicted the way
Trump did and call it indicated it's an
even bigger discount but I'm not going
to put it up anywhere okay you've just
got to know indicated is also a valid
coupon code now but I don't want to hear
anything else about it all right how
long is this arraignment going to be we
don't know
we don't know it may not last very long
and the way that everybody is acting
outside
I get the sense it may actually be quite
a short arraignment and then we are
going to see Trump and then the question
is does he plan to speak to the media it
was originally said that he was going to
or is he going to stay silent fly back
to Florida and then do his uh press
conference tonight
the president is under arrest the
president is under arrest the president
is under arrest
um okay let's see what else we have here
so many people calling in
let's see here oh hi David uh whoa look
at this we have a photograph from inside
Trump at the defense table looking
dejected folks after all this time of
this guy being the Epic narcissist
seeing a dejected Trump like this is
absolutely
fascinating let's take this right here
we're gonna capture it that is something
I'm Gonna Wanna tweet uh wow wow wow wow
wow that is really something else folks
that is a did have you ever seen Trump
look this way it isn't it is an extreme
pleasure to see this dear God look at
this
all right let's just take it all in and
you know
it doesn't take us to point out that he
doesn't look like a happy man in these
images obviously he knows the weight of
what he's going through In This Moment
flanked by his legal team but again to
see him looking at the lens taking it on
Wow straight on his eyes locked on the
camera just as it was locked on the
video camera as he walked in that
hallway just as it was when he walked
into Trump Tower last night he knows
that these images will become defining
images of Trump's uh of Trump's career
of Trump's life of Trump's political
career wow um I mean it's extraordinary
he
I I see the anger I see what John
santucci's referring to there but it's
it's it's not just anger
um oh you know
some kind of DRM prevented me from
taking the screenshot can somebody send
the picture of trumpet the defense table
to info at davidpackman.com would
someone be able to do that so when when
it was the one rally where nobody showed
up and he he walked out of marine one he
had a red make America create a hat it
scrunched up in his hand his tie undone
and he looked like a defeated man
um
that that looks like a an angry Donald
Trump and it looks a bit like a defeat
of Donald Trump
in the foreground closest to us there in
the photograph is Todd Blanche this is
the lawyer added in just the last 24
hours and the significance of that move
Kate
I think it's right there taking this
very seriously so Trump already had
several lawyers right experienced
lawyers he brought on this high-powered
former Federal prosecutor seems to me
they're taking these charges extremely
seriously whenever the rhetoric suggests
and you can see that of course in these
images I mean one thing I thought of is
a line from an opinion out of the
Supreme Court a couple of years ago
where Trump was actually trying to fight
uh Bragg's predecessor Psy Vance getting
some documents Financial records Supreme
Court this is really an iconic image
this is I'm just I'm stunned looking at
I'm speechless looking at this image and
the president is subject to the law
certainly that an ex-president is and
you can really see that in these images
and I think you're going to see
different roles for the different
lawyers in this case Joe takapina who
you see there the furthest in the
picture is very close with the family of
Donald Trump with Kimberly Guilfoyle and
Don Jr and I think that that's how he
was initially brought into uh this case
and I think now you're seeing Todd
Blanche being brought in to be maybe the
lead sort of legal voice on this Joe
Tucker all right guys I got the image of
Trump no need to keep sending it to me
42 people sent it 42 people sent it we
got it we got the image thank you
everybody television he knows the
message that Donald Trump wants to
convey
but that's different than what you argue
in court I mean we saw for example in
the 2020 uh election uh legal arguments
Rudy Giuliani sometimes would argue one
thing in court and then come outside of
court and say something very different
here at least you have different lawyers
who can take on different roles in the
Donald Trump defense and again this
comes back to the intersection of
politics and the law which is some of
the lawyer Joe takapina can maybe be the
face of the team can be out there can be
defiant can be
um you know battling it out for Donald
Trump and yet inside Court you'll have
different lawyers making very strictly
legalistic arguments I think that in and
of itself underscores the argument most
of all that he's taking this seriously
as you pointed out Rudy giulami played
both roles along the way in so many of
these moments in this case you have the
public face to to the right there of the
screen and then the two attorneys on the
left Susan Nicholas obviously and then
the lawyer added uh Todd Blanche in the
last 24 hours they are on President
Trump's right hand all right the
arraignment is well underway I don't
think it's going to be that much longer
from the reporting that we've gotten and
then Trump will come out and then we
will see him Secret Service and Court uh
police and NYPD everybody is standing by
for this and this is going to be quite
quite a moment as Trump exits we don't
know yet whether he will be addressing
the media or whether he will not
um super chats David sir your member
page isn't loading it just loaded we are
doing everything we can to scale
resources it just loaded beautifully and
both Mark Iris as well as
Kyle Fox just signed up pushing us to
304 I promise you it is indeed working
let's listen to a couple other
voicemails here
hey David yeah this uh situation is
with uh Trump is indicative of the
indictment and absolutely brilliant I'm
so happy thank you I'm watching you
You're great brother thank you so much
for what you do all right A lot of
people very very happy here hey David
only from Dallas Texas and man I can't
believe this day is actually happening
you know
you know under arrest for you know being
a criminal
you know it's a great it's a great day
for America and and I know people like
Ted Cruz my uh Shameless Senator is
saying that this is the death of the
rule of law right listen man if you mess
around you're gonna find out and I'm
sorry that the guy that you support is a
thug but you know that's you know these
things happen when you commit crimes so
yeah listen the Tangerine Terror the
mango Menace
uh
uh he's not gonna do a day of prison
time and I I want everybody to remember
that but
this is at least him not being
completely Above the Law completely
above law
David sir Bonnie from Utah hey I'm
watching your coverage it's a pleasant
day in the neighborhood
I was wondering what you think about
now having
OSD Trump
having to submit his DNA along with his
fingerprints and his photo because he is
arrested
do you think that will impact Stormy
Daniels case
because she has DNA they just need
something to match it to you know a
bunch of people wrote to me about that a
bunch of people wrote to me about that I
don't know I don't know hey Pinch Me is
this really happening oh my god did
Trump just go into the courthouse in the
courtroom aha this is the greatest day
of my life good job Dave well people are
like elated out there it's really really
crazy
[Music]
um
wow that is something else huh
David sir I cannot uh attest for Roger
Stone but uh from the looks of it uh the
former president
is fully clinched
oh my goodness
David Jeannie B here from Melbourne
Florida I've been watching you for
several years now
um just want to say what a great day
today is thank you for covering it I
feel like justice is starting to be done
and I couldn't be happier I also just
quit smoking
seven days ago congratulations that's a
great thing to do free to leave until a
judge releases him likely on his own
recognizance this is not a bail eligible
crime that he's going to be charged with
and plead not guilty to but he is not
free to go until the judge says he's
free to go so those Court officers are
there both for his own protection and
and as a I think a vivid symbol of his
predicament right now David
Aaron what's your understanding as to
how quickly the rest of us will learn
what's in this indictment
uh it should come at any moment as soon
as the proceeding is complete and our
our best indication that it was underway
is the release of these images because
the photographers that were allowed in
to Snap photos were only allowed while
the judge was not on the bench so as
soon as those photographers were
escorted out and were able to show us
these pictures that means the judge is
on the bench and the proceeding by now
well underway all the former president
has to do is enter his not guilty plea
there may be some housekeeping matters
and other dates set for a status
conference or a motion schedule and then
the the judge will formally conclude the
conclude the proceeding I'm also struck
by one other element in this photo David
behind the officers you would normally
see Spectators in that first row I was
told that those first row even two would
be kept empty as something of a buffer
between the spectators gallery and the
former president as yet another measure
of secure 30 so those members of the
public and the press that we're allowed
in are in the back of the courtroom and
perhaps Aaron you could speak to some of
the irony here as we can hear the
helicopters hovering overhead we hear
the ambient noise there above you but
some of the irony here that it was
Donald Trump's team and we know this is
a former president who has embraced the
power of the lens the power of
Television all these years as a
businessman and then obviously as
presidents of the United States that it
was his team that argued in the 11th
Hour that allowing cameras into that
courtroom television cameras would
create a circus-like atmosphere they
made a convincing argument the judge
agreed with them which is why we're
seeing these still photos instead which
is really a shame I have to say here we
are outside of the courtroom awaiting
the departure of the arrested former
president Donald Trump the arrested
former president Donald Trump we believe
any minute now he will be leaving and
heading back down to floor Florida where
he will hold a press conference tonight
at Mar-A-Lago I will be live at 7 45 PM
eastern time tonight for that press
conference which I expect to be
completely whacked just absolutely
outrageous if you're just joining us the
coupon code today is indicted and
another eight people just signed up
using it we also have a secret coupon
code which is indicated which was the
way Trump misspelled indicted on Truth
Central the other day and you can feel
free to use either or neither or both or
whatever it is that you would like
let's see what else we have people are
just calling in like crazy
and I just wanted to say it may sound
like Vehicles because I'm running a
little late it's why the arraignment is
taken all right I am not I know some
people like that type of Comedy I'm not
that's not necessarily for me I do
appreciate the call though
uh yeah Dave great job man great job
and it's good to know that the abortion
that lived
will definitely be aborted
God bless Mo whoa whoa whoa
that's pretty uh
that's pretty aggressive I don't know
that that's necessarily for this show
uh that's a bit it's a bit much it's a
bit much I have to say
hey David I just have to ask if this is
real life
from the weekend I took a trip myself to
help with my anxiety and I thought I was
still
going through it right now but I just
this is just wild man
um what a freaking day anyways I love
your show dude
thank you very much I do appreciate that
um let's see what else we have going on
here all right let's listen to the ABC
coverage and sort of it may sort of
reflect exactly the same language in a
lot of the counts just a little bit of a
different fact as to which record Etc so
we don't know exactly you know how how
detailed or complicated uh the
indictment is going to be but yes I
would expect that we should be getting
this up very soon uh they have it now
they've reviewed it he's pled not guilty
and this is the time uh for them to
release it and you know it's going to be
released electronically so there's no
you know it's not like they're literally
need to walk out of the courthouse to
deliver it to somebody they've got it
there and they just have to decide when
to release it Dan what do we see after
this I mean take us through what the
American public will see they'll enter
The Plea they'll leave the courthouse
they'll head back to Mar-A-Lago the rest
of us will start reporting out what's
inside this indictment but where does
the case go from here this this is just
the very beginning yeah this is going to
take a while I mean the first thing is
going to be they're going to be motions
right they're going to be efforts by the
defense in particular to dismiss the
case to limit the charges if they're
felonies to say the felony should go
away there's going to be a whole list of
arguments that the defense is going to
make we have an update from CBS news
that Trump has already pled not guilty
four counts
as God just noted it is worth reminding
people that
um the what's happening inside this
courtroom will not be broadcast or
photographed we just got a couple of
these still pictures from the very top
of it reporters are inside our own
Graham Cates is inside and will bring us
more details from what Scott has already
mentioned they cannot use phones or
laptops to provide updates we have to
wait until the end of this proceeding
but Scott McFarland was in an overflow
room and witnessed Donald Trump plead
not guilty was able to bring us some of
the initial moments from just what
happened in very dramatic recounting of
this incredible moment Scott when the
clerk read the charges to the former
president was the former president
addressed as former president Trump or
president Trump or just called Mr Donald
John Trump ah there were different
variations of that Bob first of all his
defensatory Tom Blanche introduce them
as former president Donald J Trump but
the court clerk referred to him as
Donald J Trump and Donald J Trump is the
name defendant here but that distinction
was made between the defense Council and
the clerk all of this is clear to see
President Donald Trump and let me
explain why these are pretty moderate
sized rooms I mean think of a large high
school classroom
maybe a small small school library or
cafeteria this is a this is a small
place and it's a grand contrast to the
federal court system to the other courts
that we walk into in which there are
Optical trials or spectacle Arrangements
um this just feels and looks different
Scott McFarland thank you stay with us
if you will I know John Dickerson is
here with us as well Scott um Eddie you
mentioned that uh D.A outenbrag is there
anything else from the prosecution table
and also did everybody March right in
and take their seats or was there any
sometimes there's a Milling there's a
little bit of Milling about in which the
lawyers at least nod at each other or
you know they have some Commerce that
they've already engaged in in setting
this moment up and they will have to
engage with each other again was there
any of that in the courtroom wow and we
see that so frequently in criminal cases
where groups just kind of assemble
piecemeal that was not the case here I
mean Secret Service is running security
along with New York police in New York
State Court police there was a regiment
here John where everybody was seated in
place with security in place before the
prosecution team arrived which happened
almost exactly at 2 15 eastern time the
Trump team including the former
president about 10 minutes later at 225
Eastern time so once the defendant was
seated and once the defense team was
seated the judge entered moments later
with the clerk announced the initiation
of this proceeding but there was a small
and micro proceeding before it that
matter of dealing with the media
requests for Access once the judge
disposed of that with no comment from
the prosecutors of the defense attorneys
they've moved on to begin this historic
indictment
I got some new reporting just in from
our investigative producer Pat Milton
noting that these charges are all Class
E felonies and to note felonies carry
prison time misdemeanors do not Ricky
we've been talking about this what do
you think the significance is that the
District Attorney's Office brags office
bumped up all these charges to these
Class E felonies which I understand are
the lowest class of felonies in New York
state Penal Code correct from a
misdemeanor punishment of a b of a year
to a classy felony with a punishment of
four years the ultimate punishment is
today fairly irrelevant except for the
fact that it carries more time because
what we're dealing with here is the
question of what are these charges so it
seems to me we still haven't seen the
indictment that if you're dealing with
one business record that they say was
falsified that it becomes one count and
then one check becomes one count the one
thing we have learned I think from
Scott's reporting is that this all
concerns the activities involving
allegedly Donald Trump with Michael
Cohen David pecker with the National
Enquirer and Stormy Daniels and not
other charges I think that's a big
Revelation if I heard it correctly Scott
is that correct
yeah although I'll have to admit and
acknowledge that we've interjected our
suite into the airwaves here by bolting
out of this hearing before it was
complete there's clearly going to be a
connective tissue between these charges
and potentially some other
misconduct or allegation all right we
are standing by outside the courtroom
Trump has already pleaded not guilty
we should see him leaving momentarily to
fly back to Florida let's listen to
people very titillated by this
continuing to call in
hey Dave
um I'm totally shocked that uh Trump is
playing I didn't play the like
laughingness off I'm a strong man uh
this is a joke I'm gonna conquer it
looks Sullen I mean he looks like he
could not drum up uh if you know a
fierce strongman attitude yep shocked
this is great it's pretty compelling
stuff it really is
hey David uh just a quick thought here
so if Trump is a convicted felon
from New York on these charges like
let's say you know everything goes
through he gets convicted yep 70 won't
be able to vote for himself in Florida
interesting thoughts vote for me because
I legally can't
listen folks I'm not allowed to vote
because I'm a felon please vote for me
instead that that is that is an
interesting one for sure
hi David this is Brittany from Florida
okay we can't deal with the audio the
audio is a little bit Criminal
hi David my name is Kimberly my husband
Alan loves you and has been watching you
um I just had a question because you
keep saying that
Trump isn't going to face any jail time
so I'm just curious as to why that is
okay so here's why I think that's not
going to be the case so far what he's
been charged with doesn't even
necessarily have to carry any jail time
if it does it's a year I think that
based on Trump's age and his status if
they're if the charges are not dropped
and if there's no plea deal and if it
goes to trial and Trump is found guilty
and a sentence involving jail or prison
time is handed down if all of those
things happen all of those things happen
Kimberly
it will be negotiated that because of
the security situation and Trump's age
at the time which will be close to 80. I
mean we don't know how long this is
going to last that he can serve it in
home confinement like at the very very
very very very tail end of this if there
were to be prison time uh I think it's
home confinement so that's that's my
sense right now it's just an opinion
that's all it is
David sir
I come to you with tears in my eyes and
dumps in my toilets oh my God I just uh
can't believe this day is really
happening it's uh hopefully a great
thing for this country to have some
accountability all right so man people
are really on fire here everyone let's
offer trump our thoughts and prayers he
is going to need them
David great show today
oh my goodness
hey David do you think it's wrong to
feel so happy and elated about Trump's
misery
I mean part of me says yeah but I don't
know I'm enjoying this a little too much
I think no because listen you know the
truth of the matter is Trump's
presidency brought so much tragedy to so
many different people
Trump is still going to be safe he's not
going to be hungry he's going to have
plenty of money you know hold on things
like people are moved I think it is fine
to take a little pleasure in this I
really do he's gonna be fine he's gonna
be fine and these at the end of the day
so far these are relatively minor
charges it is some semblance of justice
that he is not completely Above the Law
so I don't think that it is it is wrong
to do that
hey David as a kid I sat in front of the
TV with a cassette recorder watching
Nixon's resignation speech and recorded
it now here I am sitting watching Trump
be arraigned it's a crazy world man
absolutely absolutely ladies and
gentlemen I want to thank an additional
eight people who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code indicted or
indicated both work I really appreciate
it Joey says there's no way any jury is
unbiased with any case involving Trump
I've said that before I think that
that's probably true
I think that that is probably true it's
feeling like any moment Trump is going
to be leaving the courthouse there's a
lot of uh a lot of activity uh going on
here hey David I just wanted to call in
and say as a retired corrections officer
it would be a privilege to come out of
retirement to babysit that fat turd
thanks wow
people are angry huh
people are angry
hey David I just wanted to say sir you
know uh one of my trump friends
was just screaming at me but he he's a
hero and I I responded he's not a hero
and then they said but he's a hero
because he was indicted and I said
I like ex-presidents that weren't
indicted
he's a hero for being indicted Now isn't
isn't that the best now he's a hero for
being indicted
hey David this is Aaron Gross from
Houston Texas uh I just want to say uh
today's a good day bro for you and all
your watches out there I just want to
say uh it's a great day have a good one
all right ecstatic in Houston Texas you
really do love to see it big thank you
to Edward Manzo who just signed up on my
website folks we will be back live
tonight with the second stream of the
day Donald Trump is flying back to
Florida and will be holding a press
conference at 8 15 PM Eastern I plan to
cover it live it should be completely
unhinged and delusional one favor I'm
going to ask I just need to ask you a
small favor
if you learn that the press conference
is being delayed because of the timing
of trump getting back to Florida or
whatever it's about a two hour 45 minute
flight from uh from New York City please
email me and let me know so I can adjust
the start time uh that I would really
appreciate that because then that'll
also give me time to better plan
tomorrow's show and you know it's a very
very busy day so if it gets delayed
please do let me know let's listen to
uh let's listen to another voicemail or
two as we wait here hello David I hope
that once he does get convicted and he's
sentenced to home confinement that he
has to wear the ankle bracelet and also
that he's uh you know um not permitted
to open his big mouth on social media
and such and we could stop hearing from
the big orange blob
uh just a side note I had a big dump
today and I had to flush twice okay
folks please do not call in with that
crap okay literally and figuratively
please please don't do this this is a
serious program today jeez hi David B
from Chicago here I'm curious if they
give him Home Consignment in the court
in New York are they going to force him
to stay confined to Trump Tower that's
an interesting question
uh just curious super interesting
question a legal question to which I
don't have the answer right now but that
is very very interesting
it was Dean down here in Central Florida
yeah this is crazy I feel like this is
going to be something talked about in
textbooks and stuff for years to come
these pictures are going to be shown
online on lectures and giant lecture
Halls it's just hard you know being from
Florida to not think that he's going to
weasel his way out of it somehow or
somehow he's going to split through the
legal framework that seems to be
deteriorating in this country
so you know at least it's a fun little
spectacle for us yeah I mean listen if
if what you mean is he's not going to
end up serving prison time then I agree
but uh the look on his face shows that
this is not exactly fun this is not
exactly fun for Trump
Joe thanks oh my goodness
wow
all right it seems as though it's uh
we're moments away here from Trump
coming out hi David I wanted to say this
is a wonderful day but I also had a
question can someone who has been
accused of a crime still run for
president it doesn't seem yes even Trump
could be convicted and still run based
on what we have uh recently seen and
heard
hey David it's Patrick from North Dakota
I heard that next week Trump is expected
to be arrested on suspicion of being
good in bed but they're expecting him to
be released due to lack of evidence wow
tough for Trump huh
seems uh
seems crazy
David it's Jay from Tennessee
um as happy as I am seeing everything
unfold with uh the meaning of
Mephistopheles and his uh indictment and
arrest I do have a little bit of anger
that they have treated him so much with
kid gloves no handcuffs no mug shots no
nothing it just kind of continues to
show how he is just treated just a
little bit differently than everybody
else and it it quite frankly it pisses
me off yeah they're uh not treating him
like any other criminal president or no
president or supposedly none of us are
above the wall anyway just my two cents
well a lot of people absolutely feel
that way a lot of people absolutely feel
that way Mr Pac-Man hey this is uh
this is Jeff from Southern California
just wanted to tell you that we love
your show and we as my wife and I my
nine-year-old son and my seven-year-old
they're we're learning in real time the
importance of following the laws and not
breaking them anyways we love your show
man we hope everything is cool with you
and quite a lesson quite a lesson that's
for sure
hey David long time listener first time
caller just curious what do you think
your perspective is on whether this is
going to rile up the base severally
embolden the uh the crazies and um also
okay so uh on as far as that goes
I think that this will help Trump in the
primary and hurt him in the general and
as far as whether people are going to
now protest or Riot or whatever I really
have no idea I hope that they don't
I hope that they don't it looks as
though Okay let's listen hello in his
one-time fixer and attorney who actually
wrote the check to Stormy Daniels in the
closing weeks of the 2016 campaign there
were 11 reimbursement checks sent to to
Michael Cohen and each of those can
represent a count there's the bad check
there's the the bad invoice and and then
there's the bad entry on the Trump
organization's general ledger so 11
reimbursement payments times each of
those three things gets you to 33 felony
counts assuming the counts have been
elevated by some underlying crime some
reason why the the business records were
allegedly falsified what's the 34th
count still waiting to to find out as we
wait to get our hands on that indictment
wow
again the former president inside court
now for well more than a half an hour as
they go down these counts he has pleaded
not guilty to the crimes laid out and as
we were talking earlier we believe going
in and we wanted to wait until we heard
officially but we believe going in that
many of these counts would mirror one
another and that's exactly what we're
seeing play out yeah and you heard Aaron
kutchersky laying it out there right
which is that it's all out of the same
series of events and that there are
numerous counts which is not atypical of
prosecutors laying out a case and all
right so part of the delay may be that
they are reading each count one by one
that's certainly possible here's the
scene outside the courthouse news Mackle
what's Newsmax up to wanting to see
what's next guys
all right thank you very much Michael
Carter
um so we are anticipating the president
uh coming out we're we're we've got uh
Amir Beno uh with us and joining us also
Thane Rosenbaum
um a constitutional attorney at uh Toro
college and Torah University and former
lieutenant governor for the state of New
York I haven't heard of that to your
thoughts right now as we've seen this
and and that picture right there
obviously that's going to be plastered
everywhere it is right now with social
media uh you know it used to be you
would do things for the six o'clock news
right now it's for social media it
happens almost immediately so this
picture now the former president of the
United States in court being charged on
34 cats right well it raises a very
important issue which is since this
accusation this indictment is clearly a
political hit job we want the American
people not just the 12 jurors selected
from this very a lot of copium here but
the American people all the jurors in
the United States to see this trial live
on television and to do that we must
change the law because believe it or not
New York is one of only two states in
the United States that prohibits cameras
live television coverage I agree there
should be cameras yet the people should
see the legal gymnastics that Bragg is
using to circumvent the statute of
limitations to change misdemeanor into a
felony and to slice and dice one
transaction into 34 felony counts yeah
saying let's go to those 34 counts again
34 counts of falsifying business records
but look at this guy first degree I
think that phrase is is what makes this
uh even more important kind of break it
down break it down for us well Katrina
without the campaign Finance law
violation right if without that it
couldn't be in the first degree the the
district attorney could have filed this
on his own without the grand jury just
to show you how low level and offense
the falsification of business records
are that you didn't technically need
them for that you needed it to tie it to
make it a felony and that's why we're
here right because in any other instance
this thing would have just been handled
by the district attorney alone and so
the knee very incisive analysis here
about just how unfair all of this is to
Donald Trump as I'm sure you can imagine
um do I still think that the press
conference will be on time I have no
idea Trump's press conference is
scheduled for 8 15 tonight but back in
Florida and I don't know what the
assessment was about how long this was
going to last and how long it is lasting
I just don't know we're going to follow
it as closely as we can super chats are
coming in here felons can't vote correct
yeah we could have a situation where
Trump is on the ballot unable to vote
but others can vote for him which would
be pretty pretty interesting and
compelling I have to say
let's see what other
Super Chat voicemails rather we have
hi David it's Jen from Providence so I'm
in a nice liberal area now but having
grown up in Louisiana are you concerned
that some parts of Maga country are
going to erupt into riots and violence
and such as a blowback from this yeah I
hope it doesn't happen but I am worried
that the magas are going to Riot I was
just kind of wondering that too also uh
do you think in lieu of conjugal visits
is he just gonna have McDonald's and KFC
delivered yeah no that's that that could
be Trump May negotiate the bucket of
chicken and stuff like that crispy strip
meal and double double coleslaw though
he's never really struck me as much of a
vegetable guy but that that I have to
tell you that KFC coleslaw is really
something else
hey David
love the show got big massive tears in
my eyes today everybody's seems to be
enjoying today uh the photo from him in
the courtroom I think is going to be
plastered on every Mega t-shirt from
here on out I think they're just going
to use it as a woe's knee thing so I
don't know you know Trump looks like
such a loser in the picture that I
actually don't know that it really I
think if Trump had gotten a mug shot and
he could have sort of framed himself as
looking super strong that's something
Maga might have turned into a t-shirt
but Trump looks so dejected and like
such a loser in the picture that that
was shown that I don't know that Maga is
necessarily going to be uh thrilled
about publicizing that necessarily let's
listen to Chris Christie perfect example
of prosecutorial discretion you know
Federal prosecutors and prosecutors
throughout the American system are given
the discretion even if they believe a
crime may be committed to make an
evaluation is this worth the expenditure
of resources compared to the other
challenges I have in my particular
jurisdiction and I think it's where
Pierre's comments come from particularly
into Focus here you know when you look
at the timing of all this no doubt
there's doj policy that says impeachment
is the only way to deal with the sitting
president so now once you get past
January 20th doj has to look at the
resources they're bringing to Bear here
they wanted those resources to be
brought to bear on January 6th I'm sure
and that was a prosecutorial judgment
made probably by the Attorney General of
the United States and passed down to the
U.S attorney's Office in the southern
district of New York to say we're not
wasting our time and resources on this
our Focus regarding Donald Trump's
conduct is going to be on the
intervening problem of January 6th and
what crimes we're committed there by
people by people in this orbit by the
people on Capitol Hill
and ultimately maybe by the president
himself and so you know prosecutorial
discretion is an important part of what
makes our system different than the
European system for instance and this is
where I think Alvin Brack is going to
get himself open for the most criticism
with crime running as rampant as it is
violent crime in the borough of
Manhattan and all across the city of New
York remember crime rate is higher in
Oklahoma City all these resources that
are being spent on this matter a
seven-year-old hush money case is that
really making the security and safety of
the people Manhattan better and is this
really what they should spend their time
on doj obviously made that determination
regarding this versus January 6th Alvin
Braggs made his determination they'll
both be judged by it legitimate
questions all to be asked in the days
and weeks ahead Chris Christie thank you
let's bring in Heidi heitkamp uh former
Senator heitkamp and and Heidi you've
been watching this unfold here today and
and just just your initial reaction here
to learning 34 felony counts of
falsifying records
my initial reaction is Donald Trump is
not a happy man we're getting video from
some apparent clash between supporters
and detractors of trump let's take a
look
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the presidency he needs to move one
group that he lost between 16 and 20 and
that's Suburban republican-leaning women
and they aren't going to like what they
see in this indictment they aren't going
to like you know Donald Trump's between
a rock and a hard place politically
right now because if he acknowledges the
liaison and says it was no big deal I
did this you know purposely ndas were
signed then then you're going to have a
bad political problem with the group
that you need to secure for the
presidency and so the political
ramifications are very Stark here in my
opinion you know we asked the governor
we've asked him a number of contributors
here Heidi what they made of the three
or four seconds of the former president
going into the courtroom you know he
lasered in on the camera those still
images of him flanked by his attorneys
uh you know you've watched the Trump
years unfold what did you make of those
images
and if you
stink eye at the camera I don't think he
feels defeated nearly as much as he is
seething with anger because he is not in
control he thinks and believes that this
is all nonsense and he's got to go
through this very difficult process and
at the end of the day I think he's smart
enough to know this this may reignite
the mega base he may be the Martyr for
the Mega movement but this is not a a
procedure that helps him secure the
presidency of the United States correct
hi Kim Heidi we always appreciate your
contributions as well our thanks to you
and to Governor Christie I want to bring
in mark up to Grove presidential
historian LBJ all right we're continuing
to monitor for Trump's exit deceive it
must also show that there was an intent
to deny an individual or in individuals
of properties or financial assets and
they think that will be a very stiff
climb in this case trustee as I
mentioned is also part of the Mar-A-Lago
classified documents case and he pointed
to the fact that other attorneys in that
case have been present before the grand
jury for the special counsel and most
notably Tim parlatore parlatory told me
personally that when he went to the
grand jury in December that he felt his
testimony to the grand jury was
unexpected and unhelpful his words to
the special counsel because he argued
that his actions and the actions of the
former president did not show a
willfulness to retain the records rather
what he described as a willingness to
provide back the records once they had
been identified it does seem as though
the court officers are sort of starting
to get a little bit bored let's see
what's happening out outside the
courthouse
Bragg is going to be relying on covid to
get around the statute of limitations
argument because during the the lockdown
Governor Cuomo and then Governor hokel
imposed a toll on the statutes of
limitations in criminal and civil cases
so if you subtract the two years from
that toll it brings you right within the
five-year window of the statute of
limitations that you would need in order
to charge these crimes against President
Trump so of all the galling things that
came out of covid I expect this to be
just another one there's also another
argument sorry that adds to what Amir
said which is that Donald Trump there's
an argument to be made that you have to
be consecutively in the state so the
fact that he lived in Florida the fact
that you lived in Florida in New York I
mean in DC as President also the justice
department has office of legal counsel
has its own policy that while again
while you're president of the United
States you can't be prosecuted and the
time period within that you're staying
in the white house doesn't count against
statute of limitations yeah and I want
to get to our political analyst Mark
Halperin who also is here with us a lot
of shaky shaky stuff happening here as
far as as far as a lot of this legal
speculation goes that's for sure as we
monitor a number of different feeds and
stand by for Donald Trump leaving his
own indictment leaving his own
indictment let's see what else we have
hi David uh this is Carrie from
Minnesota love your show
um I'm just quite you know I guess my
hope for our country is that Donald
Trump not be able to run for office it
scares the cheese economy that he could
end up our president in 2024
even if convicted of some of these
crimes yes it's amazing but it seems I
recollect a case where a judge actually
ordered a January 6th defendant like at
sentencing to leave his office I I you
know it seems like it was a local state
that this man was elected to possibly
city council something like that and at
the time of sentencing the judge in that
case you know noted I believe a federal
statute saying you're convicted of this
crime you can't hold office any longer
can that occur with Trump we're getting
very very far ahead of ourselves I don't
know I don't know about that but that is
great question we will have to explore
that
um I just don't have an answer at this
point in time I don't
hey David great day congratulations to
all of us uh light thinking decent uh
human beings in the United States of
America it's pretty good stuff thanks
for covering it uh I just have a
question about the the Republican
primary if Trump does not end up the
primary candidate for the Republican
Party
do you think that he will start his own
uh party as he has alluded to in the
past I would love for Trump to do that
it would destroy the Republican party it
would truly destroy the Republican party
if Trump did that
hi David I'm a long time listener this
is Tony from Louisiana
and I just want to say what a great day
it is today watching
the maggots
meltdown over mango Mussolini finally
finally
facing Justice anyway have a great day
David I'm enjoying the show enjoying the
live feed hope everybody's
um relishing in
knowing that today it was proven in
America that nobody is above the level
wow
all right very very powerful stuff doors
are opening let's watch our eyes are
trained there's some activity here
Secret Service coming out uh let's just
stick with this live picture
the former president let's listen
there he goes and there you have it a
rarity all right Trump now exiting and
then will presumably make himself down
make his way downstairs and out of the
building we will see if he issues any
kind of statement upon leaving uh or
whether he just gets directly into his
vehicle to fly uh presumably to go
straight to the airport and right back
to the State of Florida we just don't
know what his plan is at this particular
point in time but we are very very soon
going to see
this is the view outside this is also
the view outside and we are keeping an
eye on all of it uh let's see what is
our best shot
I guess maybe this one here
you know Ricky which is barring some
theatrics you know somebody is there a
reason that it would take that long just
on the indictment itself
um reading it out or is there some
process that would take an hour or does
an hour tell you something well I think
an hour is rather long for uh an
indictment but we don't know what
happened in terms of scheduling we don't
know if there were arguments about any
other kinds of motions
um we really don't know until we find
out from people who were in that
courtroom and hours long for an
arraignment they usually take about 10
15 minutes tops even and then the judge
says and the next date that you will be
here for a status hearing is Right
February March whatever it may happen to
be and I'm using past months
intentionally
um that it it should not have taken this
long so something happened in there and
we'll find out what it was Ricky play
this out for us as a lawyer let's say
this first time offender Donald Trump is
ultimately convicted of this crime of
these 34 charges what kind of prison
sentence if any could they face oh give
me a kind of penalty could Trump uh have
in his future if he's ultimately
convicted he's facing a mandatory excuse
me he's facing a discretionary four
years in prison correct because these
are 34 counts we are told but they don't
stack them one on top of another because
it's all part of one scheme so it would
be looked at really in essence as one
all right as you can see and so you
would have there is action in the
background and people getting to the
vehicles it seems as though here we have
the overhead shot yeah so it genuinely
does seem like Trump is going straight
back to his vehicle not making a
statement which is definitely out of
character for Trump but maybe he is
finally now listening to his attorneys
and not saying anything did we even miss
Trump getting into the vehicle I I now
wonder uh I I didn't see Trump get into
the car we don't yet know whether a gag
order has been put in place but it does
seem as though they are getting going
and they will work their way presumably
back over to the FDR and then I don't
know what airport oh LaGuardia actually
was the airport that Trump's plane flew
into funny story I haven't been to
LaGuardia for a very very long time
years and years and years
but the last time I was there it was
while Trump was president and the Trump
plane was just sitting at LaGuardia
Trump was President he was flying on Air
Force One at the time so but it was just
sitting there it was very unusual
um all right I guess Trump got into his
car deeply himself and that it was Todd
Blanche this is the new attorney that
Donald Trump brought on to the team in
the last 24 hours at least acknowledged
it publicly that there had been an
additional defense attorney added who
did most of the speaking inside that
courtroom here and and David as you see
those images of the motorcade leaving
what the Secret Service wants to do get
him in and get him out
they wanted this to be very
business-like professional I think they
probably even negotiated with the Trump
team that he probably wouldn't do much
speaking at the courthouse either before
or after that's what you're seeing
unfold
he will be moving toward the airport
promptly we're being told so again for
their all right ladies and gentlemen the
former president of the United States
Donald Trump has been indicted on 34
felony counts he has pleaded not guilty
to all of them and is now heading to the
airport
this is going to conclude the first
stream today and I know many of you have
tears in your eyes over what is going on
here as we see Trump in this iconic part
of lower Manhattan so so familiar to so
many of us working his way up presumably
to Laguardia Airport assuming that his
plane is still there and hasn't been
stolen or moved to a different Airport
tonight tonight Trump will be giving a
press conference at 8 15 at Mar-A-Lago
folks make sure you're subscribed on
YouTube and following on Twitch so that
when I go live tonight with the press
conference you will be notified and that
will be a beautiful
let's hear that that was weird that will
be a beautiful moment all right
everybody thank you for joining me Trump
arrested indicted see everybody tonight
that's in about four hours and 45
minutes congratulations everyone